e
e e
okay the time
being 10:02 we'll get started um and
first up I'll open the public hearing on
hb42 thank you very much Mr chair
members of the committee for the record
my name's Dave luno um representing the
people of Hopkinson and bo uh
conquered actually used to be in my
district too so I don't give them up
very easily and um and as I always like
to
say we also all represent people all
across the granite state because um uh
because the issues that come before this
committee have statewide impact on uh on
all Granite Staters and uh and I know
we're always trying to do the best thing
for um uh for for everybody together so
so um anyway I'm here this morning to
introduce House Bill 402 with which is
relative to liability um as taxable
income of Education Freedom account
payments so uh we've talked a lot about
putting guard rails on the state's
relatively new uh education Freedom
account uh program the governor even
mentioned support for things that would
strengthen the program during her
inaugural address and that's what we've
been talking about too things like fraud
prevention things like eligibility
requirements things like Criminal
history background checks for service
providers things like accountability how
well do we know um how do we know how
well the kids are doing we just don't
know things like being subject to a
state performance audit how do we know
whether the program is performing
according to the law we just don't know
but unlike these guard rails to
strengthen the program House Bill 402 is
more about being truthful honest to
taxpayers who are
taxed to pay for the voucher program and
honest to families who participate in
the voucher program it's simple it
repeals the one line in RSA 194 Fon 2
Roman 6 that reads quote funds deposited
in an EFA shall not constitute taxable
income to the parent or the EFA
student so let's hold on for a second is
New Hampshire currently saying in state
law that EFA funds are not subject to
federal taxes
so let's be clear I'm not here to say
that EFA payments are subject to federal
tax or exempt from federal tax I'll say
it again I'm not saying that EFA
payments are or aren't considered to be
taxable income by the IRS in fact the
IRS has a web page titled do I include
my scholarship fellowship or education
grant as income on my tax return they've
got a website on this and it includes a
tool to determine whether these EFA
payments are taxable in any case it's
not our role at the state level to
determine what is or isn't taxable under
federal law and more to the point we
should not provide bad information to
our constituents when it comes to
federal tax liabilities that's both
misleading and
deceptive so what what's going on at the
federal level so Senator Ted Cruz of
Texas actually filed legislation in past
sessions of Congress to amend the
federal tax code to make education
Freedom accounts free of federal tax
liability to the student and to the
family so straight from that uh Senator
Cruz's bill it reads quote not treated
as income the amount of any such
scholarship shall not be treated as
income to the student or their parents
for purpos of federal tax laws or for
determining eligibility for any other
Federal program and you can actually
find this on page nine of Senator Cruz's
bill but that legislation failed so
what's this all mean
well maybe it means that EA EFA payments
are taxable at the federal level I mean
why else would Senator Cruz have filed
um that
legislation so tax law is really
complicated I I know you guys know that
I don't have to say that in the ways of
Means Committee I'm on the education
committee um but as an engineer I I can
I can attest to that
too uh I don't have an llm in tax and I
don't have the tax chops to get into the
weeds of the federal tax code but as a
taxpayer I know that some income is
taxable and I know that some expenses
can be deducted from certain income for
example a 529 distribution used for
tuition has no tax liability but a 529
distribution used to buy a laptop might
be subject to federal
tax so what's this all mean it means we
should recommend this bill isad to pass
so that we're not providing misleading
or deceiving um information to uh EFA
families when it comes to the tax
liability that may be incurred or maybe
we should amend this and recommend it
ought to pass as amended so it's not
misleading and at least let these
families understand their federal tax
liabilities and let taxpayers know how
efficiently their money is being used
for a public benefit program like our
school Voucher Program passing this bill
is honest transparent and responsible to
voucher families and to taxpayers and
that's what we should do I'm happy to
take some questions uh I I know there's
some experts um uh sitting behind me
that can can take very technical
questions representative
y thank you representative for taking my
question uh regarding this particular
Bill I'm sing you like like I received
1099s corre
before however the money my
understanding of the current EFA
situation is that's already
been accounted for as either taxable
income or tax exempt income is that your
understanding as well my yeah my my
understanding um and this this is is
only based on the uh the technical
advisory that uh that the IRS has
prepared the one that I that I talked
about that that some things uh some
scholarhip um money is would not be
subject to federal income tax if you Us
in certain ways but other scholarship
money um would be subject to federal
income tax if used for certain things so
so it's just it's it's it's different
all understood and if there's subtleties
as to where the revenue is
originated uh can may I use the analogy
that this appears to be a 10 pound pound
Sledge
when a finish Hammer may be necessary um
and and and I I appreciate that um that
that that point representative vior and
and um and like like I said I I I I
think you know this committee could
certainly um you know see to it to make
our laws not misleading or deceptive to
to families um so that they can consider
whether or not their pay whether or not
payments Direct Ed by them um through
the children's scholarship fund to
service providers are or are not subject
to uh federal income tax the um there
there is a section in the in the
legislation that um that that calls for
1099s uh when uh when I I started a tech
company many years ago and I know there
was a period of time where uh where
where where our company needed to
provide 1099s to uh to various Supply
suppliers that were over a certain
amount I'm not sure where that law
stands today uh but but certainly that
could be something that could be pulled
out of this this bill and and make it
really just uh just clear to um uh to
families that uh that they need to work
with with their advisors in terms of
what's taxable and what's
not thank you you're welcome
representative Malloy thank you Mr chair
thank you for taking my
question can you or maybe somebody else
give us an example of what you would
describe as
misleading in in something an example of
what uh this might be to help sure um
where where the where the misleading
part is in
um is
uh sure I get the right section here
is in the in our current
law and our current statute for efas in
194f there is
a there is a a a
sentence and I referenced it yeah in
194f Colon 2 uh Roman 6 that reads quote
funds deposited in an EFA shall not
constitute taxable income to the parent
or the EFA student my understanding is
is that I mean clearly New Hampshire
doesn't have an income tax so and New
Hampshire could set its own tax policy
with respect to New Hampshire taxes but
this doesn't talk about whether it's a
state tax or federal tax taxable income
well we certainly don't have that in New
Hampshire so I'm assuming this would
mean this would lead me to believe it's
talking about federal tax liability and
um and as a state I don't think we're in
a position to determine what what
constitutes federal tax Li ability so
that's that that's really the subject of
of this bill um is uh is eliminating
what what is potentially misleading and
deceptive any other question yes
representative so just to be clear
representative um as some people have
asked me about this legislation this is
not an attempt to impose a tax on
efas this is simply to say that under
federal tax law
which I'm certainly not qualified to
describe at the moment either but under
federal tax law certain kinds of
expenditures from the EFA fund could be
potentially taxable is that that's
that's correct and and and you know
there was there was some uh
very poor um uh journalism uh uh maybe a
couple months ago that that sort of
alleged that that this was the state of
New Hampshire looking to impose a tax on
voucher payments no this is not about
that at all I mean it was a um uh
obviously it it it it contained that
that story um contained some really
really wild wildly incorrect uh uh
statements including statements from the
commissioner of Education that suggested
that the state maybe should tax you know
the per pupil amount that get sent to
public school districts so so uh should
tax students for that which which you
know it just it it just clearly showed
that uh that the the people who were
making these statements hadn't even read
the bill so um so but thank thank you
very much for thank you thank you Mr
chair other questions
I guess I have one question
representative
um has there been any instance where
this is uh you said this line uh the
state has no jurisdiction over has there
been any court cases regarding this as
far as you know I'm not I'm not aware of
any Mr chair okay thank
you all right thank you very much
terrific thank you very
much next I have um py Campbell
uh good morning uh my name is py
Campbell I am a retired State Rep from
Farmington New Hampshire had the honor
of serving on the house education
committee and was immersed in uh a lot
of the education funding bills and I'm
happy to report that 20 plus years later
we target money to communities we use an
adequate education grant to do it and we
meet our constitutional obligation uh by
funding the cost of
adequacy um House Bill 40 402 should be
voted inexpedient to
legislate uh or amend it to include
taxation on all students who receive an
adequate education grant for attendance
in a government run school program the
equal protection Clause of the 14th
Amendment of the US Constitution states
that all people in similar situations
must be treated equally by the law this
bill is a violation of that by
separating out students who receive the
Constitutional obligation of adequacy
payments through the EFA
program students in government run
schools receive the same Financial
benefit as the state pays directly for
the adequate education cost to
government run schools providing that
Educational
Service this bill is a solution looking
for a
problem we need to cut spending and find
reasonable uh resources for paying for
the cost of education we should not be
taxing spending programs that we are
constitutionally required to provide for
the cost of the opportunity for an
adequate education that's what our state
law says does anyone think taxing the
education trust fund will help pay for
the cost of providing for an adequate
education I that really concludes my my
statement but I I think there was I I I
obviously
think that this is a tax would create a
tax for taxpayers in New Hampshire um
just because we don't have an income tax
I'm a self-employed businessman so I pay
the business Enterprise and the business
profit tax and anyone situated like me
that receives this EFA program to their
students would then have to pay add that
to their state income which is an income
tax on llc's so this is clearly a tax on
anyone who owns their own small business
and it's a it's a regressive tax uh
specifically targeting a program that
has wonderful benefits um I think this
is a great program it should continue to
be exempt from New Hampshire uh small
business taxes that are a form of income
tax and I hate to admit that in my no
income tax state of New Hampshire and my
Live Free or Die beliefs but the reality
is if you change this legis this
language in this bill that anyone who's
self-employed would have to declare this
income on their state tax return and
they would be eligible to add that to
whatever their business Enterprise and
business profit tax obligations are I
don't think that we should tax education
funds I know there's some great
philosophical divides and I respect
those in the the validity of the program
the the program I obviously believe in
it um but that that the idea of taxing
money from the education Trust fun I
hope no one in the Ways and Means
Committee would think that that's even
remotely a good idea this is a foolish
legislation and you should vote it itl
and I thank the committee for their
time thank you uh do we have any
questions seeing none thank you thank
you okay up next I have Stephen
ma Matthew Matthew what's youf your
French uh my name is Stephen Matthew I
own legacy Financial Solutions and lfs
Tax Group we're tax uh tax and
accounting firm serving over 1,200
clients in the state of New Hampshire
many of whom contribute uh to the
education Freedom accounts uh and uh uh
many of are assisting in in getting this
off the ground uh right for back from
2011 or 12 when Tom deblo and the state
senate first uh proposed this type of a
thing um we've uh looked at this uh and
and we basically feel that this
particular bill is a is a bill in search
of a problem that doesn't exist uh first
of all uh representative uh was it Luna
Luna uh didn't didn't mention Pub 970 uh
IRS Pub 970 which basically exempts uh
and I'm going to just read you the
specific language uh the value of you
know a fellowship Grant or scholarship
that is provided to an individual uh is
excluded from income the value of
contributed services and accommodations
this includes services and
accommodations such as room lodging
boards meals uh that are received by an
individual as part of a scholarship or
Fellowship Grant the amount of tuition
matriculation and other fees that are
paid for remitted to the student to Aid
the student in pursuing the study or
research and any amount uh received in
the nature of a family allowance as part
of a scholarship or Fellowship Grant
that's all right out of Pub five uh Pub
970 IRS uh nobody I don't know any
accountant across the country that would
ever assume this to be taxable income uh
the the Ted Cruz bill was merely to make
absolutely certain that nobody tried to
tax these things because there are
people out there that would read into
things things that don't exist and and
it's just absolutely for clarification
second point I would make is does
anybody here know what the annual gift
tax exclusion is in in the for Federal
gift tax purposes this year it's
$199,000 all right in addition to that
you can make what are called exempt
gifts so a grandparent for example can
pay tuition education fees uh cost room
and board for a student going to any
private or non-public institution and
that is an exempt gift so it could be
$57,000 to go to Union College it could
be uh to go to a high school all right
well basically the rich can do
this but if what we're doing is we're
setting it up a potential for taxation
for the rank and file for for low low
income or moderate income people why
would we do that you're hurting the very
people that need this the most it makes
no sense and so my point is don't even
consider this leave it let the Sleeping
Dog lie this is as far as the federal
government Pub 970 is concerned as far
as us as tax preparers who have been
dealing with clients you know we we have
1,200 in our tax business uh we've never
ever uh you know included any of this as
as taxable income so that's my point
Steve Matthew I'm with lfs Tax Group
thank you would you take questions yeah
uh represent you uh thank you Mr Matthew
um IRS Pub 970 could you uh get a copy
to us of of that any of you can access
it just by putting in IRS Pub 970 on
your phone and it'll come right up yeah
okay and the uh the gift tax do you know
off the top of your head where that is
what publication or what line is covered
with that uh I have tax charts and they
the IRS puts those out every single year
as to what the the tax code is and what
the exemptions are and so if anybody
wants to copy that I'm glad to get that
to you oh will you take I'll give you my
my email address is Steve lfs taxr
group.com and I'll send you the tax
chart if you'd like it Steve at lfs as
in Larry Frank stepen tax
group.com thank you that would be very
helpful okay will you take one more
question sure uh what would be the cost
to prepare and send out for each one of
the individuals who receives uh an
EFA
form 1099 form well if they all of a
sudden have to start doing a tax return
because of this particular
income whatever you know whoever does
their tax returns if they did it on
Turbo Tax it' be one thing if they did
it uh through an accounting firm like
ours our minimum fee is 250 but yeah
that's not exactly what I'm asking to
prepare and send out the 1099 oh that's
a another uh thing on behalf of the
uh dispersing agent would would it's
going to cost them typically you know
for us to send out 1099s for some of our
client business owners it we're charging
$100 because a 1096 has got to go to the
IRS and then another $35 per $199 that
we have to send out so it depends on how
many they're sending out so if you have
an organization like here in New
Hampshire have children's scholarship
fund and I don't know how many
recipients they have be 2,000 figure the
cost the time the postage of getting all
all of those out could be substantial
and it significantly adds to their
administrative cost thank you sir I
appreciate
that anybody else uh just a simple
question the 19,000 was that 2025 or
2024 2025 okay thank you y
and the last pink card I have here is uh
Bill
arder thank you Mr chair members of the
committee my name is Bill ardinger I'm
an attorney with the law firm young and
Pignatelli and conquered um I am here on
my own behalf on behalf of myself I'm a
tax attorney I am not here on behalf of
any client of our firm many of you know
that our firm represents clients this is
in my role as uh in my personal role um
I had the pleasure of serving on this
Committee in 1980 to 82 when I was a
student at University of New Hampshire
um that started my love of tax policy
and tax law I went to Washington for a
few years and then came home to New
Hampshire where I raised my family and
I've worked as a tax lawyer since that
original introduction to tax law on this
committee uh in in 1980 um I also
recently had the pleasure of being
appointed by Governor sonunu to the 2020
education funding study committee and I
had the opportunity to serve with
representative luno representative Ames
and many other folks representative lad
on that committee during that effort we
looked at the entire scope of New
Hampshire's public school funding system
not only the traditional system for
150,000 plus students but also um uh
education Freedom account which is up to
around 5700 students now so I would like
to comment in support of the key part of
House Bill 402 which would repeal the
section that representative luno said
which says that the education funding
account payments are not taxable income
to the parent or the families I believe
that is inaccurate as a matter of
federal tax law and I'll walk you
through why uh here in a minute and I
believe that
the state of New Hampshire should not
put what could be viewed as tax advice
into a statute and that tax advice could
be
wrong and someone could rely on it and
suffer consequences so if I could please
just uh I do have on page three of the
report before you a a brief summary of
the New Hampshire EFA program I'm not
going to focus on that but what it does
do is it has the state funding payments
oh uh uh to the scholarship organization
the children's scholarship fund which is
the administrator and they provide
payments to the education service
providers who are uh previously
registered for the benefit of specific
students eligible students who are
designated by the state of New Hampshire
that's our program on page four uh I
Focus exactly on the statutory section
in the bill the 194 F2 funds deposited
in an EFA shall not constitute taxable
income to the parent or the EFA student
that statement is incorrect and state
law has no power to change the effect of
federal tax law I would like to turn
next on page five to the actual section
of the Internal Revenue code that
governs the taxability for f federal
income tax purposes of scholarship
payments that section is section
117 of the Internal Revenue code that
section says that if you receive certain
payments qualified scholarships and the
amount is used for qualified tuition and
related expenses that that payment is
exempt from federal income tax so there
are payments that are scholar ship that
are not taxable under federal law what
are those well first tuition and
fees um that are uh for the purpose of
the Stu enrollment or attendance of a
student at an educational organization
that's a defined term and fees books
supplies and equipment required by
courses at that educational institution
an educational organization is defined
as as an entity
um that is normally maintains a regular
facility and curriculum normally has a
regularly enrolled body of pupils or
students at the place where its
educational activities are regularly
carried on this is what you would think
of as the traditional Paradigm of a
scholarship payment it's something that
has gone to help people attend you know
University of New Hampshire or or or
something like that that's the
traditional it is this is a longstanding
section of the code and it is well
established on page six um our my my
prior colleague who testified talked
about a general publication 970 which
applies to all income the IRS has issued
a publication uh specifically on
scholarships fellowships and other
grants and they say exactly what's
tax-free and exactly what's taxable
amounts used for incidental expenses
such as room and board travel optional
equipment payments receed for teaching
research and other services as a
condition for the grant these other
expenses are taxable but a pure uh
reimbursement for tuition at a regular
school uh with a regular student body
and a regular curriculum those are
exempt uh from taxation under the
federal income tax law
um I we've noted some on page seven some
of the federal legislation this issue is
an issue in Washington there there are
several bills in addition to Senator
Cruz's bill there's other bills like
house uh uh HR uh
9462 that would seek to expand section
117 to include things like online
educational material costs college
application test costs educational
therapies for students with special
needs provided by accredited
practitioners and similar homeschool
costs importantly under current federal
income tax law costs associated with
homeschooling that you receive a payment
for those are not exempt from federal
income taxation as a scholarship payment
um if we get to the next section this is
where the this is the clear example
representative ol and I I think
representative Malloy in RS in the EFA
statute there's a list of expenditures
that are covered that are eligible under
the EFA program those go through a
paragraph a through o on this one page
taking risks with how complicated the
federal income tax laws are I have made
an attempt to show the uh issues that
this bill supposed to address of the two
of the entire list a through o only two
paragraphs are likely not taxable and I
would say likely because the facts of
every case matter uh paragraph a tuition
and fees at a private school those
should be uh eligible for exemption
under Section 117 of the code in
addition if you go down to m m is the
traditional paradigm uh tuition and fees
and an institution of higher education
those should be exempt from federal
income tax law if you look at every
other item in the list of eligible
expenses for the EFA program there are
questions about whether those payments
would be taxable under the federal
income tax law some of them that I
marked in red absolutely
taxable and uh recipients who receive
for example tutoring Services provided
by an individual or a t tutoring
facility there are actual guidance out
there those are
not uh tax exempt um scholarship
payments they are not and if you look at
other ones for example educational
software and applications unless those
are mandated by a regular school with a
regular student body with a regular um
uh group of students
they they are not exempt from federal
income tax so of all of these payments
that are indicated under the EFA program
that are eligible there are significant
parts of that that are not eligible for
scholarship exemption treatment if we go
to uh the problem is page nine here's
the problem of
misleading I was not that worried about
this when this issue first came up with
the original EFA because the EFA Pro
program was limited to very very lwi
income people and in many cases you only
have to file if like married filing
jointly you you only have to file a tax
return if your gross income is over
around 30,000 so under the original
versions of the EFA program which were
focused on low income it was kind of
like a no harm no foul many of the
recipients aren't filing tax returns so
failure to declare these payments as
taxable income if they are wouldn't
expose them to violating federal tax law
however uh it it there you know when if
you look at the next page 10 the federal
poverty level times
350% we're up to a family of four
earning
109,000 that's guaranteed that family is
filing a federal income tax return if
that family of four receives $5,000 per
Stu per child and they do homeschooling
on an online program that isn't part of
it those amounts are taxable that would
be $220,000 that's roughly the average
that the based on New Hampshire doe
that's a problem for the State of New
Hampshire and this committee and this
legislature to say in a statute that the
amounts received under this program
shall not constitute taxable income that
potentially misleads a recipient to
thinking well I don't have to report
this on my federal tax return that is
wrong if we come to conclusions last two
pages and be happy to take question EFA
payments may be taxable income 194 F2
Roman 6 is inaccurate it should be
repealed HB 4022 seeks to avoid
misleading EFA families it seeks to
protect the state from possible lawsuits
in the future that they gave incorrect
tax
advice and it definitely as
representative luno says repealing this
section does not impose any new tax
that's a ridiculous characterization
that was in that journal article and and
I I was I was stunned that someone would
say that and then finally the final page
is just a reminder I have had the
opportunity over my Years in New
Hampshire to structure many programs
including the business Finance Authority
back in 91 and many many more I love
this state and my my key in structuring
programs
always do it with due diligence and make
sure that you're not you know making
unintentional payments of a stream
that's designed to benefit citizens of
this state families of this state that
were taking slices out unintentionally
and so if you look at you know the
current traditional structure is well
established when a kids go to a regular
public school they don't have any income
they're receiving Services it is not
taxable but in this more creative
alternative program this effort at
reform there is a risk that you're
taking slices so your dollar of spending
that goes through the EFA Pro through
the public school program gets you a
dollar of services but a dollar of of
through the EFA program is being charged
the you know up to 10% cost by the
administrator and also potentially for a
family of four you know at 350% of
poverty potentially costing 20% you know
rough tax rate federal income tax rate
that would mean you're getting 70 cents
of service and is it possible to
structure this program so that it
doesn't have this risk yes but you'd
have to limit it to the clear categories
that are taxfree under federal income
tax law I'd be happy to take any
questions and I thank this committee for
its work thank you representative
YY good to see you again thank
you well I shouldn't say good Oh Come
ones um
firstly I pay taxes for my local school
if I were to give money to private
school in town why can't I take that off
as a expense as well the answer to that
is if the private school has gone
through the effort of qualifying as a
501c3 organization and many of them have
they would be a charitable organization
under 513 and under Section 170 your
contribution to that school would be uh
um tax deductible with one exception
representative over if you give the
money to the school and you say strings
attached I want that money I gave to the
school to benefit my kid on a
scholarship that would not be deductible
and that would um that they that would
not qualify there's clear law on that so
you can't
designate the the charitable deduction
for a particular
student po thank you okay
I understand that
um I'm trying to synthesize you've
worked with the
legislature got to get this down to one
page yes got to get it down to one
paragraph correct New Hampshire cannot
set federal law requirements correct
easy easy that's exactly
right New Hampshire can is uh set limits
on what it considers taxable income
absolutely no we do not have an income
tax absolutely
right and the ruling I think your your
key phrase in here this was an issue for
and from Washington to handle uh if the
federal income tax law has a question it
is for it only Congress and Washington
can fix
it but at the same time the current EFA
law which the members should have um
needs to be modified in certain
areas so it's not the terminology of
taxable income is not
misleading uh regarding the federal
obligation that may or may not
exist correct only each family that
receives the benefit of the EFA payment
can make the decision on their tax
return whether it is taxable or not it
would be kind of an easy thing if if I
believe this Paradigm case if an EFA
payment is made to to the scholarship
organization and then paid to a one a
501c3 uh religious school let's say like
a a traditional catholic school in town
here for example and that covers tuition
costs of attending that is exempt from
tax under Section 117 I can say that
with a with with a Clarity because it's
that's exactly what the law is in
Washington and the federal law is
intending to exempt but if it gets into
things like a payment where the family
uh purchases internet
connectivity or or uh uh SAT test prep
cost those things are taxable only the
family knows the state can't know that
so the caveat is caveat
empor well let let me just say this
caveat empor is not what this sentence
does the sentence that's in the law
right now has the situation where
someone goes hey uh I'm filing out like
uh doing it myself on on uh on turboxs
I'm not going to declare this 20,000 for
the four kids that are being home
schooled cuz the state statute says it
and I'm going to rely on that and then
all of a sudden let's say they get
audited not a common occurrence but
let's say they do and the auditor says
you should have reported this did you
intentionally not report it and all of a
sudden that family is in a world of pain
they've got potential civil penalties
there's potential criminal penalties and
all of a sudden that family gets all up
in arms says I've had to hire a lawyer
stinking lawyer cost me a bunch of money
I'm going to sue the state to reimburse
me for misleading me that's where it can
bite so Caveat Emptor is if you leave it
blank and you don't speak one way or
another I think the state has properly
left it in a caveat empor state but if
you have this sentence in the law you're
tipping the balance where you're biting
on a risk which is potentially
misleading a family well you don't have
to the state doesn't have to speak on
the taxability federal taxability you
can't
and just to the
merits both all the people who testified
are right this program is a program you
know has been around in places like
Milwaukee where the Public School
Systems have clearly failed in
Washington DC where they clearly failed
voucher programs are important uh
avenues for reform in the right place on
our education funding committee study
committee we found out that New
Hampshire's public school system which
educates about over 150,000 students
every year is in the top 10 in terms of
quality of outcome and top 10 of
supporting Public Schools our public
school systems are working based on our
study and there is a real question to
get this program right don't make foot
faults you can make this program right
you just got to think about it and be
direct about your your knowledge on the
applicable law and risks representative
ducet thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking my
question excuse
me
yeah so in in your testimony can we
agree and I was a little confused with
something you said and maybe you can
just answer this for me the the
recipients or the benefactors of DFA
programs do they get those funds in hand
they do not get those funds in hand okay
so if they do it's a
violation exactly to my point um those
funds are distributed to Providers
correct so I guess my question to you is
how is it that a lowincome family that
derives a benefit from an
EFA with a benefit that they've never
seen in hand comes up with the money to
pay what you believe is a taxable
component we you know they're applying
for and
benefiting with the efas but all of a
sudden they have to pay out of pocket
for a tax on a dollar that they didn't
put in their pocket representative I
think it's a great question so think of
the
traditional scholarship payment kid uh
goes to Claremont Stevens High School
like me and my wife we I met her there
uh and the the uh
kid applies for scholarship the
organization grants a scholarship the
organization pays the amount to the
University of New Hampshire for the
benefit of this child or this student at
that point and it it reduces the cost to
that student of the uh tuition for UNH
in that case the dollar has never hit
the student
pocket and the law says in that
situation that flow of benefit the
student clearly benefit didn't put cash
in the pocket and then transfer it to
the to the uh school but the the the kid
benefited in that case it says in
general all income is subject to tax and
that includes benefits like that but in
this specific case the IRS code the
Internal Revenue code says that
scholarship payment to UNH is not
reportable as taxable income by the kid
this situation if we had a situation at
the federal level where you had a
student apply for a scholarship and they
paid the money to a tutoring firm it was
not required by un and that tutoring
firm provided the service for the
benefit of that student that would be
taxable under Section 117 even though
the cash didn't hit the kids pocket when
then he paid to the student to to
Tutoring company it in other words
that's the way it works for federal tax
law follow up I I appreciate your your
position on that but we're talking about
uh optional Post Post Elementary
education here to to apples and
oranges you know you you're giving me an
example about University components
we're talking about through 12
representative that is required I can I
used it because that's the Paradigm I
can change it to uh a private school
scholarship to a private k212 school
exact same
treatment no difference under federal
tax
law okay and and we can agree to
disagree and there's two two uh opinions
on
this do you think that don't file a tax
return like that well no I just heard a
tax attorney tell me that this is not
taxable and he would not file that so so
we have differing opinions I guess my
question to you is this can we excuse we
got have one person talking at a time
right now Sor should in your opinion the
New Hampshire legislature get into
having voice in what is federal tax code
in our statute is that what you're
suggesting we should not say a thing
about federal tax law in our stat
that's what this bill does it's it
removes saying something about federal
tax law on our
statute and and how
we no thank you okay U I've got a couple
more questions here but let me
um let me just ask
does the federal tax code uh or no does
federal law preempt state
law in
almost all
situations yes there is a supremacy
clause in our
Constitution and they it so if Congress
enacts a law in a field of law like tax
it it it is but in this case the tax
only sets the federal level of tax in
terms of
preemption the Congress has has passed
some laws that would preempt States from
imposing taxes on certain income uh so
they've done it there but it's it's a
complicated question yeah so um and is
ignorance of the law a a defense no it
is not okay so if somebody looks at this
and says oh I don't have to uh file but
they don't have the full picture they
didn't look at the federal law then
technically it does the state have
liability because we all know federal
law preempts and you should have looked
in the federal law as well it it would
be it it's kind of one I appreciate the
question uh Mr chairperson they the the
the question is the way I'm hearing you
frame it is hey we could leave this in
here because no one's going to actually
be able to ultimately sue us because we
weren't intentionally misleading them
and they were not they were making their
own decision but why would you have a
potentially incorrect statement in the
statute you could change it by saying
funds deposited in EFA shall not
constitute taxable income under any New
Hampshire uh tax you could put that in
and that would be accurate because it's
definitely not income under the bet it's
that which I helped Governor
Merill write the BET back in 93 it it's
definitely not taxable income under the
business profits act we don't have an
income tax of any other kind that would
tax it
okay thank you representative duet um
actually I'm sorry let me well you kind
of a just along those lines you'd agree
with me that the the IRS has a
robust uh compliance and auditing
system that they they follow so if
there's an
issue it's their horse to chase correct
they yeah absolutely thank you
representative om yeah thank you for
your uh summary of very complex tax laws
my question is has there been any
adjudication of the New Hampshire laws
either now that's been adjudicated or
pending representative moment it's great
to see you again uh no there has not to
my knowledge been any case addressing
remember what we see right now happening
across the country is the increasing
expansion of this
alternative uh Education Service
delivery regime vouchers or efas or
whatever you call them it's happening in
Arizona it's happening in Ohio happening
in Florida North Carolina and
potentially New Hampshire there have
been no cases representative home I
think principally because the scope of
the programs has been very narrow
limited to lowincome recipients who most
of the time are not required as you know
in in in in the United States 50% of the
you know filers don't pay any federal
income tax and and and so it's you know
the bottom line is I don't think it's
been a problem that has generated
litigation that's why the cases don't
exist however we're on the cusp of this
problem as the expand as my testimony
shows as the expansion is
happening representative Spar thank you
Mr chair um understand everything you've
done said so far uh the section that is
in the bill about uh issuing 1099 can
you just comment briefly on your
perspective of that yes I did read that
I'm not commenting on that my testimony
because I don't think that is quite
correctly frame with due respect for the
sponsor of the bill uh the 1099 there is
no 1099 requirement right now for uh uh
the scholarship payments um and and and
the at at the federal level and we can't
say anything about as a state for the
same reason we can't say anything about
the taxability of these payments under
federal tax law we can't say anything
about the reportability of the amount
this issue has come up before in an
interesting Way section 529 of the
Internal Revenue code the college
Savings Plan account New Hampshire was
the first state in the country to
establish one of these plans the unique
plan Fidelity is the administrator I
represent Fidelity in that effort and we
got the first IRS letter ruling for any
state on that plan in that situation
Congress passed a law ordering the state
college Savings Plan programs to pay a
1099 to beneficiaries who receive
dispersements from the 5.9 plan without
that Federal enactment there would be a
no 1099 there is no 1099 requirement
under federal law so in my you've asked
I'm not focused on it I don't think that
section of this bill uh uh is is
accurately framed there may be something
about notice that's required that's a
decent discussion point but I'm not uh
commenting on
that representative Southworth and then
representative tney thank you Mr chair
thank you for taking my question I part
one and part two on part one do New
Hampshire CPAs have page
eight page
New Hampshire CPA's uh do not do not
this page eight the first time it's seen
the light of day is to this committee
okay so the New Hampshire CPAs however
have great access to the actual Internal
Revenue code all the regulations under
the Internal Revenue code and the
publication that directly applies to
scholarships and fellowship grants which
is the one that's cited in my t Okay
seems like again in the future maybe
they will need to um part two um I I
don't do it but are there sections on
turbo Cam that would lead someone to
know what qualified uh expenses were did
you mean Turbo Tax or Turbo Tax yeah I
have prepared my own personal tax return
on Turbo Tax I have never had to address
a scholarship payment and therefore I
don't know the answer to that so this is
very new basically for every I I think
these this the this type of question
coming up is new because this this
Pathway to Educational Service provision
is is is relatively new in New Hampshire
we do 150,000 plus kids through the
traditional uh system of delivering
public education and only 5,000 plus
kids so it's it's brand new really
still uh representative tney thank you
Mr chairman thank you for taking my
question my grandson is in college yeah
and I know on his
taxes they're asking if he received any
scholarships so some way shape or form
if that question is on his uh tax form
whether the individual be like that age
or a parent they'd have to answer it
correct yes if that and again sorry I
don't personally have experience with
that my grandchildren are seven and four
and one four of them so I have few years
on you follow up follow up okay one
section in here under
194 talks about the parents of an EFA
student shall agree technically meaning
that they're getting the money if the
verbiage was changed to the student
receiving the money that would lower the
threshold of income tax that was
necessary unless the child was extremely
wealthy on its own correct it it's a
complicated question in this regard if
this if the some kids were going to
college are still dependent on their
parents return and whether they're
filing their own individual return or
not depending on their income level but
in
general if you could probably try and
structure it that way to reduce exposure
to having that child have to file a tax
return and and have the income be deemed
to be received by the child um it could
happen but that's complicated and and
bottom line represent attorne it's based
on the facts of the particular case and
the state of New Hampshire shouldn't say
anything about how they go to their Tax
Advisor and resolve these questions
their Tax Advisor should help them and
they should do it personally with look
at turbox thank
you um this is just maybe more your
personal opinion on um I I also use
Turbo Tax and um if if the example you
gave where somebody goes and uses Turbo
Tax and they see this and they mess up
and eventually they sue the state isn't
Turbo Tax the one that's
liable I I I again I think if Turbo Tax
gets something wrong
they are potentially are negligent and
there could be potentially a claim
against them that's possibly true but if
the person says you know I read New
Hampshire's law it says it's not taxable
income I relied on that do I think that
that's going to be a large money risk to
the state like um the YDC cases or the
youth services cases that we're seeing
in the state right now no it's
definitely not there's 5,000 Plus
uh families here
nonetheless I think representative luno
deserves credit for raising a bill that
says why mislead potentially families
when we don't have to we're not
achieving anything with the sentence no
that that makes sense I guess my concern
is this has been in here for a long time
why is it in are we are we missing
something if we if we get rid of this
are we somehow creating some other
problem I think that's a fair question
let me say where I think this came from
I remember when the EFA thing came up
this sentence was in the statute at that
point it was very very low income right
and and so I was kind of I just I love
the state I love this committee's work
and I pay attention right I I I've
always done that representative Aly
knows I've tortured this committee for
many many years and and um and and uh
you know I heard about this thing I said
well that's a crazy sentence what I
think happened is that in the Arizona
law there is a sentence like this in
some of their
Publications I have I'm betting dollars
to Donuts I do not know this it's a
personal opinion represent G again that
someone who was drafting this just
simply copied it didn't really think
about it okay and and that is the source
of it in that original hearing I heard
back from my wonderful colleagues that
um uh attorney uh Deputy assistant
Assistant Attorney General an Edwards
who's now a judge on her Superior Court
she told the committee you can't do
anything about federal tax law but it
still went in I I I don't believe
removing this is going to have any
adverse effect it's like a free one all
right thank you all right thank you very
much you very much okay that's all I
have for pink cards and uh we're only 32
minutes over um oh we've got another
oh wait a
minute all right representative AES okay
good good morning and uh I said put two
minutes down on that card I think I can
keep it to one um I'm a co-sponsor of
this bill I
uh did I I co-sponsored because I think
it's uh unwise for the state
to give advice as it's essentially doing
in this uh case on on federal tax law in
the absence
of clarity that simply does not exist in
this situation you've heard uh um Bill
aringer Mr aringer um who certainly
knows tax law tell you that uh there is
uh that this this statement that's in
our code is uh misleading I think it
should be either removed or
uh amended revised so it's not
misleading anymore it's a simple matter
to do that either way and I encourage
you to do
that thank you all right and your idea
of amending it would be um not taxable
to New Hampshire uh or not taxable in
New
Hampshire by New Hampshire by New
Hampshire yeah okay something like that
thank you
okay thank you very much
and I now have one last pin card John
Reynolds and
uh is John Reynolds
here what's
that oh yes it says 503 okay good then
why
I'm uh is is there anyone else that
would like to speak on
402 okay seeing none I'll close the
public hearing on HP
402 okay thank you
okay e
okay the time being
11:06 I'll open a public hearing on HB
483 and
welcome up representative
luno thank you very much Mr chair
members of the committee excuse me for
the record um my name is David luno I
represent the people of Hopkinson and Bo
and uh like we talked about earlier um
like to consider uh all of the the work
we're doing as as um meaningful to Grant
Staters no matter where they live and
and so what we've got before you next is
House Bill 483 relative to the
definition of a scholarship Organization
for purposes of the education tax credit
um program so excuse me so the intent of
this bill is to improve the clarity and
relevance of financial reporting from
the nonprofit corporation that
administers the state's education tax
credit and education Freedom account
programs so the um uh the title of the
bill cont only contains the um uh the
reference to the education tax credit
program and that's um that's
specifically because the administrator
of the program called the scholarship
organization is defined in RSA 77 colon
G1 uh which is actually the education
tax credit statute uh but that
organization also administers the
education Freedom account program and
the IFA program statute in 194 uh- Fon
one uh defines the administration as
defined in 77g Back to the education tax
credit so that's sort of the Nexus of
how the the scholarship or a scholarship
organization administers both the
education tax credit program it was
started there it was defined there and
now also administers the education
Freedom account program um so when we
talk about this organization this is the
organization that's the contract ctor
that administers both the both the
programs I just talked about the ETC and
the EFA programs and retains up to 10%
of the funds uh used in these programs
including uh nearly $75 million of
taxpayer funds appropriated in the state
budget over the first four years of the
um of the state's um um uh education
Freedom account
program and while it's perfectly clear
the money used uh for funding the
voucher program is taxpayer money there
is absolutely no doubt that the money
retained by the contractor for
administrative costs that 10% of the $75
million so far that money is taxpayer
money and part of the state contract
approved by the governor and executive
Council the children's scholarship fund
of New Hampshire posts the New York
nonprofits tax form 990 uh as its
audited financial report doesn't have
any independent audited financial report
or anything that's separated out from
the children's scholarship fund uh
operating out of New York that um uh
that operates as a scholarship program
for um uh for many other states so so
our um New Hampshire education Freedom
count program and education tax credit
program are buried in a national
organization's uh IRS form 990 which is
the uh uh tax form for um uh as you know
for organizations that are exempt from
income tax so the contractor that we're
working with here in New Hampshire is
doing business as the children's
scholarship fund of New Hampshire but
it's actually not its own nonprofit
organization um and doing business as
instead doing business as part of a
nonprofit organization based in New York
um uh that does work um uh in a bunch of
other states with 20 two uh partner
organizations who are also nonprofits
located in the I guess the 20 other
states that they do business in and um
and and and what it does in those other
states or for those other states or with
those other states is very different
than what it does for uh for New
Hampshire through the ETC and EFA
programs so the way it's organized right
now raises a lot of questions why do all
the other states have their own
organizations nonprofit organizations
Incorporated in their states how do we
know if our taxpayer dollars are being
used to fund programs in other states
why is the New Hampshire Department of
Education so adamant to block the
state's audit of the voucher program
even when the contract itself between
the state of New Hampshire and the
children's scholarship fund is clear
that the state has ownership of all the
data that comes out a result of these
programs and so as a nonprofit
charitable organization it raises a lot
of questions too the children's
scholarship fund um New York is a
scholarship organization it receives
charitable contributions from people and
organizations all across the country and
identifies and selects applicants
students who are applying for
scholarship from all around the country
scholarships from all around the country
to
receive this money the New Hampshire
voucher business is very different the
money comes from the state and the
recipients are defined by law and
administrative rules the recipients are
actually defined in RSA
194f and the and the education rules
that correspond to that and they're not
subject to the discretion representative
luno can I just ask you you put three
minutes down and you're at six minutes
how much more you have I'm really at the
end you're almost done yeah thank you
very much Mr chair I'm sorry about that
so um so it's not subject to the
description of the contractor sounds
more like a service provider a
contractor that takes 10% off the top
for their administrative fee not a
charitable function simply
administrative so this bill would
require the contractor use to manage the
tax credit program and the voucher
program to be a New Hampshire company
and to file its own IRS forms um that
would clearly show how the taxpayer
money is being used it's about
transparency it's about honesty and it's
about making sure our own nonprofits are
charitable organizations and not just
administrative service providers thank
you okay thank you and and if we weren't
so far behind I would have let you keep
going just get no I I I I appreciate
that thank you Mr chair okay
questions
representative thank you Mr chairman and
thank you for taking my question did you
say we couldn't access an audit on this
so so there um there was state law that
was passed and signed by the
governor two years ago maybe I don't I
don't have it in front of me that um
that that required the state actually
required the um the the the Auditors in
the legislative budget Assistance Office
to conduct a performance audit on the
the education Freedom account program uh
my understanding is that uh is that the
the the audit scope uh has been uh
limited substantially to a point where
the information that the that the LBA
Auditors were looking for uh while the
information exists uh they were not
receiving access to that information and
um the commissioner of Education uh went
before the um the is it the joint
committee on state audit is I think I'm
if that's not the title of the committee
I think it's close um and um and said
that uh that he would refuse to uh
enable access to that
information follow up I just thought
your testimony was that I'm looking at
the annual audit on EFA accounts on
their website on the fact sheet so it it
is there for that that's not an LBA
performance audit that's um that that's
simply the the um Department of
Education saying this number of students
received the these amounts of of um of
EFA um deposits and payments through
through those accounts and um and in
fact in a um in in what's called a
monitoring exercise that the Department
of Education conducted last summer on 50
efas 50 EFA accounts so that's 1% less
than 1% because I think there's north of
55200 EFA accounts but but in the in the
monitoring exercise on 50 EFA accounts
they found
25% had um had had substantial um um
inconsistencies or non-compliances with
state law and state um regul on this
including students who were not eligible
to to receive these vouchers um uh
payments that that were not directed in
the in the right way and um and that the
um the children's scholarship fund did
make U restitution to uh to the state of
New Hampshire for um uh for the um the
the amounts of State money that were um
that were not approp that were
misappropriated but I have not heard
back from the I asked the department
whether whether they appli that to the
the remaining
99% of the uh of the accounts but uh uh
uh there's no indication anything has
been done on that followup I guess my
question to you is I'm looking at it
right now you 50 applications were
viewed and two were
found ineligible how how does that
equate to
25% looks like the
$188,000 received were both were return
the if I'm reading this right but my
math isn't that good but two out of 50
is 25% so so so thank thank you for the
clarifying question uh what they what
they determined initially was that
25% and uh and then they drilled down
into that and found that the children's
scholarship fund was not using the
proper information uh in determining
residents of the um of the um uh of the
students and um uh and and and once the
uh once the proper information was used
they were able to address some of the
non-compliances but other
non-compliances as the representative
mentioned uh did remain
outstanding represent
elme thank you um I don't know how many
of us have seen charitable
1099s um is it 1099 I 99 9.99 thank you
my my head is full of cold at this point
on on but they are available online
could we get a copy of the the new of
the New York State one that we are part
of see how it's
treated yeah yes you you can you can
download that
online I guess as I read um the fiscal
note representative um the um it sounds
to me like uh there's only one it looks
like there's only one chable
organization right now and if this bill
goes through it would be none would that
imply that that would effectively kill
the EFA program I'm sorry I'm I missed
oh the fiscal so in the fiscal note uh
when I read the first paragraph there
under methodology and it seems to imply
that there's only one charitable
organization that's uh valid in New
Hampshire but it's it is approved um and
your change to the bill where cross is
out qualified to do business
um that would imply organization out of
state um it it sounds like that's the
only organization and if that goes away
then it would kill the EFA program and I
understanding that correctly so um the
the intent of the bill is not to kill
the EFA program it's also not to kill
the children's scholarship fund of of
New York but it's simply that the
children's scholarship fund of New
Hampshire the the company that's doings
business as the children's scholarship
fund of New Hampshire should be
incorporated in the state of New
Hampshire as a as a nonprofit um uh
entity just as um as these operating
entities exist in the 20 other states
that um that that provide these
Services um I mean I I certainly
wouldn't mind if it was incorporated in
New Hampshire the problem would be
timing because if this bill goes through
it gets passed um the program is dead
until some somebody you know register so
I I guess yeah yeah I mean I think there
I think there is
um I think there is another uh nonprofit
that uh that operates in New Hampshire
that that that does these I'm not sure
about the the name of that it's not the
children's scholarship fund but but if
the if the timing of this is the um is
the problem then changing the uh the
effective date on this I think would uh
would make a lot of sense uh because it
does take some time right to to to apply
and get approved as a 501 that would be
my concern representative
duet would you agree would make sense
and it's my understanding um that the
children's scholarship fund uses a
shared services model that keeps costs
down so why would why would it make a
difference where they're Incorporated if
they're delivering the service here and
they're keeping the cost low if they're
in Maryland B you know based there what
what's the difference as long as they
complying with the statute and keeping
the cause now for us yeah I think it's
basically for transparency and when you
when you take a look at the um the 990
from the um from the children's
scholarship fund of New York you'll see
um uh that uh that the other states that
they do business with are very different
than how they're doing business in New
Hampshire in fact nearly 40% of their
program Revenue uh comes from the state
of New Hampshire which is obviously not
what they're doing
um in other states but but at the same
time they there's not that level of
detail in the in the 990 and um uh and
and it's it's it's impossible to tell
from looking at the 990 that is working
with other partners in 20 other states
and working with New Hampshire uh how
they're you
know how how the the how New Hampshire's
you know tax dollars are being used
there's just no way to tell from
that representative y thank you Mr chair
I'm a
little
confused I belong to an organization
that belongs to an international
organization National and
international going
[Music]
on some 8 million members
worldwide each one of this local
areas like New Hampshire has 74 local
Council in the Nights of Columbus each
one of them files their own
990 even though none of them right 501
C8 or threes 501
C8 within the state of New Hampshire as
a matter of fact they can't be because
of the franchise structure that was
alluded to by representative ducet
why would we treat this particular
business any differently than already
existing federal law
governing similar corporate
structures and the amount of money that
the Knights of Columbus or the Masons or
handles it substantially larger than
anything that's the educational trust
fund is touching sure so so no I
appreciate the the the question and and
I think if the children's scholarship if
the company if the children's
scholarship fund of New Hampshire not
its own organization was filing their
own 990 as you've said the your your
organization the and the member
organizations in the state you said each
file their own
990 if the if children's scholarship
fund of New Hampshire was filing their
own 990 then then I think we'd have the
uh the visibility and transparency that
we need but they're not filing their own
990 unlike the 20 other states that that
are that are doing this so so um so
potentially you've identified um you
know another way to to approach this
this
problem representative
opal thank you Mr chairman and thank you
for taking my question representative
um yeah I was reading a story that
admittedly was from September of of last
year in the conquered
monitor in which it said that um there
would finally be a performance audit of
the oversight of the education Freedom
account this coming
spring but then in the second paragraph
it says but the audit will be missing
quote most documents pertaining to the
EFA program end quote due to the quote
lack of access to primary program data
and information end quote according to
the office of the legislative budget
assistant which is responsible for
conducting the
audit um and you may not be able to
answer this question but to your
knowledge has that statement changed has
there been a new finding from LBA that
they will have access to that data um
thank you thank you very very much for
the question um my understanding is is
goes right back to to to that and um and
that that access was being to to the LBA
felt they needed to properly conduct a
um a performance audit was they were not
being given access to the information
they felt that they needed that there
was a um uh a a revision made to what's
called audit scope so it was called
limiting the audit scope and that the
LBA will in fact conduct an audit
conduct an audit um uh corresponding to
the new limited scope but uh but uh but
their answers to many questions that
come up in that audit will um will you
know basically have to say something to
the line of access to certain
information that's necessary for the you
know responsible um um you know
management of the program was uh was not
provided so so you know so I think you
know that that would lead someone to
conclude that there were ineffective
management
controls great thank you very much
great thank you very
much Beckie
Campbell former
State yeah
I'm thank you uh Packy Campbell former
rep and New Hampshire
businessman um I'm a I'm anque position
in that um I've been able to through
some of my llc's actually donate to this
program and then uh due to my uh my uh
great business acun on some years was
not so great so I was actually eligible
for the program and I have one student
who's a senior in high school who is uh
receiving the EFA program and it helps
my family tremendously to be able to
afford tuition in a private Catholic
School um that I I feel important um but
really I'm here today to ask you to find
this bill inexpedient to legislate um
we've seen this bill in years passed in
the policy committee um and I think it's
it's bad policy but it's also um the
bill is written is contrary to the
commers Clause that requires us to
recognize outof State organizations to
do business in New Hampshire we cannot
limit the rights of charitable
organizations to act as scholarship
organizations in New Hampshire would be
limiting the rights of them to register
which this this organization has done to
do business in New Hampshire and would
prevent them from preventing uh from
Distributing the education Freedom
accounts this is just simply
unconstitutional because it violates the
Commerce Clause that we have to
recognize a New York charitable
organization to do business in New
Hampshire we can't discriminate against
it we can't prevent them from the
opportunity to get this 10% funding fee
it's just simple Commerce and I agree
with you they're being paid to do it and
then the Hampshire Branch does benefit
operationally from this 10% and um I
believe actually they run the
organization for less than the 10% of
the 5800 students and they actually give
uh some of that 10% out as additional
scholarships which I think is amazing um
the full faith in credit clause in the
US Constitution requires states to honor
the laws and judgments of other states
if another state set up a charitable
organization uh we need to recognize
that Char of organization when
registered to do business in New
Hampshire to deny in any way the right
of a Char of organization because it was
formed in another state is a
constitutional
violation the equal protection Clause
again the 14th Amendment of the US
Constitution states that all people all
corporations similarly situated be
treated equally under the law any
nonprofit registered to do business in
New Hampshire can act as a scholarship
organization it doesn't matter if it was
set up originally decades ago in another
state it's set up in this state it's
registered of the Secretary of State
website to do business in the state um
so given the tremendous constitutional
conflicts with the proposed Bill the
committee should vote itl on the
legislation better
yet due to the Constitutional violations
this proposal it is appropriate to send
this to Supreme Court to get an opinion
of the
justices so we can get this repeat
poison pill proposal from continuing to
be a backdoor attack to hurt or
eliminate the education Freedom account
program in New Hampshire as a business
owner I appreciate being able to make
donations to a scholarship organization
registered to do business in New
Hampshire and and the EFA is a brilliant
program because it allows to make a tax
deduction contribution federally
lowering my federal tax obligation to a
nonprofit and then that keeps the money
in New Hampshire for New Hampshire
students to use it this is you know if
you're on the ways of me many this is
the most wonderful thing we can do
instead of business owners sending money
to the federal government we're able to
send it to a nonprofit scholarship
organization so students in New
Hampshire can use it for educational
services so this is a very valid program
that we should protect and Mr chairman
yes if you pass this legislation that's
rented it would effectively eliminate
the program I don't know if that's the
intent I'll take the representative at
his word but it is certainly the effect
if you pass this bill as written thank
you thank
you okay let U representative you
set thank you Mr chairman and thank you
for your testimony in taking my question
I'm doing some digging as as we're
hearing the testimony here uh and you
alluded to a 10% administrative cost
would you believe and would you accept
7.9% administrative costs being a a
pretty good deal I think that's an
excellent deal and I think it was
actually 7% in 2003 so I think it was a
little bit lower but I think they're
doing a tremendous job they're
tremendous organization the the fact
that they were formed in New York and
the fact that they run 22 other programs
throughout the country
that this was originally a program run
by New Hampshire organization and they
merged with the children's scholarship
Network to get these efficiencies to
provide better services and they've done
that they're a well performing
organization to exclude them would be uh
travesty of
Justice repr
elmy thank you I find it extremely
difficult that New Hampshire has put
itself into the situation where it is
the only one of
21 uh organizations under the New York
Group which um hides its own
information by leaving it only in New
York isn't there some kind of difficulty
with this and why would we be doing that
when every other state organization
has has um as happens with all all other
sorts of nonprofit organizations every
other state has also put out
990s of its own representative I I
respectfully um do not buy the narrative
that this program is not very
transparent again as a a participant in
the program you're reimbursed up to the
adequate education grant so I know
there's 5,800 kids in the program I know
the adate education grant amount so
therefore I can do simple math and know
that this is approximately a $24 million
State program I know clearly that 10% of
that number is $2,436 th000 that there's
no Shenanigans there's no hidden stuff
here the the student receives a class
wallet that is managed by this their
stewards of the money the money doesn't
go to the family it doesn't go to the
student it goes to the organization the
organization then Cruise expenditures
out of the class wallet and most of the
time those expenditures are uh in the
form of a reimbursement so understanding
how the program works the narrative the
false narrative that you're hand hearing
about this program being anything other
than very transparent it's just not true
I I agree that if you want to look at
the New York tax returns of this
charitable organization you could get
some some stuff I don't think that the
New Hampshire Branch I can't speak from
them would be happy to provide you any
information as one of the
representatives is is showing their
website is a plethora of information for
how much money they spent of the 10%
what their actual operating costs were
that the respectfully this is just a a
trojan horse to be a backdoor attack on
this program I respect that some some
stakeholders don't like the program some
stakeholders like the program this if
you want to destroy the program I would
ask you to file legislation to just
revoke the program but don't do it in a
way that you try to be cute with saying
oh you were formed out of state and it's
not transparent so now we don't want the
program I'm asking you to be be
transparent and and I think this program
is
transparent follow up yes Mr Campbell I
am not talking about being cute I am
talking about obeying the
general uh method of transparency that
is done by 20 other states in the same
Pro program and
on and it is easily solved by
extending the I
believe uh automatic uh
legislative uh expiration date on the um
um sorry my head is full of
cold at this point but on the the
effective date enough that they can in
fact incorporate in New Hampshire the
way all of their colleagues have done
elsewhere in the country I I I apologize
representative I did not mean to call
you or the sponsors of the bill anything
derogatory and I retract my statement
about cute I just I just I do think it's
it's important for the commune to
understand that this this bill um would
have a negative effect on the program
and I think that um it's not necessary
for this for transparency for the for
this organization to have to be reformed
and be a a uh a nonprofit that was
formed in New Hampshire um I just I just
I just disagree with that uh statement
um but I didn't mean to be disrespectful
to you or to the sponsors and I
apologize to the committee
thank you representative Malloy thank
you Mr chair thank you for taking my
question I appreciate your uh uh talk
about constitutional questions and so
on
uh
however I
think I'm still working toward the
transparency of this and we as a group
here are responsible for taxpayer
money here in New Hampshire and I think
in my view would you agree
that more
clarity more uh information should be
made available to us as we spend
taxpayer money as laid out by the
presenters of the Bill thank you I I
think transparency is is absolutely
important with with taxpayer dollars and
I want to thank this Committee in the
state of New Hampshire for the taxpayer
dollars that they've allowed me to spend
to help offset the cost that me and my
family have born for decades to send you
know my five children to private schools
and I don't take lightly that that right
to receive a Catholic
Education um was always dependent upon
the size of your wallet and this program
was the first program in full
transparency that allowed lower inome
and middle inome people and even you
know really I think higher income people
I don't believe in the income limit um
the
opportunity um to put their kids in an
educational environment of their choice
and to not be fiscally discriminated by
that so I think that the transparency
given that we know the amount of the
money we know the number of kids that
receive it any other question that this
committee has I'd be happy to get you
that information I think it's readily
available on simple Google searches I
think that the the organization is
incredibly transparent we have nothing
to hide we have nothing up Our Sleeve
this is a wonderful program that someone
has to manage these State dollars like I
don't think you can just send the money
to the parent and not know where it goes
so this this class wallet this this
nonprofit managing the funds is very
similar to the the government uh schools
the public schools um receive state
funds four times throughout the years
and they're the stewards of the money
that you send from the state we have to
have someone be the steward uh for this
money I would be in support of um you
know work working with representative
luno to do a compromise that if you
wanted the EFA money to go directly to
an educational institution where a
student attended the school i' I'd be
open to to some kind of uh compromise
that perhaps would alleviate your trans
transparency or alleviate your concerns
about this nonprofit receiving 10% and
quite frankly I'd rather the 10% go to
the school that's providing the
educational service so I think there's
some room for discussion here and I
think there's room for compromise if the
concern is the 10% and the transparency
of where the 10% is being spent or how
it's being spent and I think that's a
legitimate question I do think it's
available on on public documents but the
the money itself the grant amount and
where it goes to the student and the
fact that it's so well regulated by the
program itself through the class wallet
and through the nonprofit and how funds
are dispersed or reimbursed is very
transparent um but if you would rather
the money go directly to you know my
local Catholic school that operates in
the basement of my church I would
welcome that because that would put
another 10% into that institution that's
providing the Educational Service hope I
hope that answers the question all right
one more question uh representative
Southworth thank you chairman and thank
you for taking my question I think you
had a lot of good facts I agree with a
lot of you what you said glad your
business and other things um uh have
been working out my question is would
you agree that it raises many red flags
when an organization blocks a normal uh
audit because that was part of the bill
that was how we were going to know if it
was doing well and successful and the
audit the normal one that the lbas do
has been
blocked um I I obviously I can't speak
to State agencies blocking Audits and
and but I uh I do respect that everybody
has you know different opinions on every
object and Regional people can disagree
I again would just say I don't think
we're blocking very
transparent uh disclosure on how the
state funds are being spent and that's
where I think this committee needs to
focus like this committee has readily
available whether this is uh non the
bill itself is about whether or not a
nonprofit that was formed decades ago in
another state can do business in New
Hampshire this bill is not about the the
transparency the the language that is
being changed is simply preventing the
one scholarship organization from being
able to continue to do its job so
although I respect the conversation
about transparency and I think it's a
very correlated when you're talking
about the subject matter it's Germain
but it's really not the matter before
the committee the matter before the
committee is are you going to violate
the constitution and three different
Clauses of it and say that a
organization a charitable organization
that was founded decades ago in another
state can't do business in New Hampshire
can't participate in this program and I
I disagree that we should just comply
and form a new uh nonprofit because a
representative wants you to no we should
respect the Constitution of the United
States of America the laws of the State
of New Hampshire and the Commerce Clause
and not go down this road it would be it
would be very poor precedent for any
legislative oversight committee to
follow what's really happening here in
this bill it's inappropriate
thank you Mr Campbell
um I said no more questions all right
what what representative
y the supremacy clause applies however
the Interstate Commerce Act also applies
Corporation can't do business in New
Hampshire unless it's registered in New
Hampshire I would disregard your
constitutional argument because I think
you're maybe Mis uh representing or
conflating it with
uh other types of activities I'm just
make that as a as a general comment
because you're crossing state lines so
the Commerce Clause is actually the
governing clause in this action as
opposed to the supremacy
clause um supremacy clause did apply for
example on U gay marriage that's once
you're married that's State you're
married in every other state except now
the other states recognized it so I I I
appreciate the gay marriage comment I
think that's a great analogy in 2003
when Massachusetts made gay marriage uh
legal uh it was a big controversy here
it's a State Rep and and as a Republican
state rep I voted to recognize what the
state of Massachusetts did and I'm glad
I was on the right side of history on
that because it was the right thing to
do this is a very similar thing you have
to recognize that New York has a right
to form a nonprofit and that that
nonprofit has a right to do business in
New Hampshire and to your question that
nonprofit did take the step of
registering at the Secretary of State
and they're registered to do business in
New Hampshire what this bill does is it
it takes out the clause or registered in
New Hampshire it basically takes away
their right to Simply register in New
Hampshire like every other Corporation
or nonprofit can do and because it does
that it does it does in my limited
constitutional opinion they gave me one
when I became a state rep um and I and I
read it and these three Clauses apply
because that nonprofit corporation has a
right to the business of getting that
10% fee and that's why it's a violation
of the Commerce Clause because they're
doing interest rate interest rate
business and you're limiting their
ability to do interest rate business so
again I think I've i' I've had more than
an opportunity here thank you all very
much I hope you'll just find this bill
inexpedient to legislate as we did in
the last legislative session and I I
would give serious consideration to to
doing the opinion of the justices
because we're doing the same thing over
and over again we're filing the same
bill over and over again let's let's
find out if it's constitutional let's
just put it to bed and then if it's
constitutional we can come back and have
a real talk about how we might want to
implement it thank you Mr Campbell
okay uh the last pin card I have is um
Sten mat
Matthew good morning again and uh I just
want to follow up on the last speaker's
commentary uh and just give you some
examples um my wife and I have been very
much involved in establish ing uh
charitable endowments and charitable
endowment
foundations uh we have set up Donor
advised foundations uh give you an
example we've got a Fidelity donor advis
Foundation we've got a an American
endowment Foundation American endowment
Foundation is headquartered out of uh
Ohio and Fidelity charitable is I'm not
sure if they're in Massachusetts or New
York or Delaware or wherever but they
are registered to do business in New
Hampshire
just as children's scholarship fund is
registered to do business in New
Hampshire and if you look at the way
this legislation is written the way this
legislation is written where do we stop
with that because in essence you can
stop and say okay Fidelity charitable
can no longer do business in New
Hampshire or American endowment
Foundation can no longer do business in
New Hampshire uh children's scholarship
fund if we go back when the original
bill was passed allowing something of
this nature back in 2 I think it was
between 2010 and 2012 sometimes uh they
were one of the first organizations that
Incorporated their business they they
did uh register in New Hampshire and
then ultimately for purposes of of uh
economies of scale uh they were acquired
by and merged into children's
scholarship New York uh the net result
of that was they were able to keep their
administrative costs down dramatically
now as a an accountant a tax preparer uh
we're dealing with this a lot and we
deal with a lot of nonprofits and uh one
of their biggest headaches is having to
file this kind of paperwork 990s what
have you so if you look at the uh the
fund itself children's scholarship fund
and by the way my wife and I contribute
to that uh each year uh for purposes for
tax purposes for our two businesses
Legacy Financial Solutions and lfs Tax
Group so we can take it advantage of
what we think is a really good program
uh but the the fact of the matter is
that uh an an organization that's giving
out uh roughly 92% or a little more than
92% of every dollar collected and only
88% is hung up an administrative fee
that's that's terrific by charitable
standards and so what we're trying to do
here is to uh continue to minimize the
cost minimize the exposure and uh to the
other gentleman point the fact of the
matter is that if you do want the
financial information you can get it uh
the the gentleman who introduced the
bill indicated that roughly 40% of the
New York money comes from State of New
Hampshire well if that's the case he was
able to get that information we also
know what's going out the door and and
and uh and then if we had 50 you know
5,000 or so people taking advantage of
the program for them to have to come
back and reimburse there were I think
there were three I I think the
representative do set so there were two
but I think there were three that they
had to reimburse uh because they were uh
not properly uh uh the funds were
improperly distributed and the
organization turned right around and
reimbursed the state uh so I don't think
we need to take this legislation any
further I think we should just rule this
as uh inexpedient to
legislate thank you okay before I
recognize uh for questions let's just
keep in mind we are 50 minutes behind
schedule um so let's try to stay focused
on what's really critical representa
alme yes the point we seem to be missing
is that presumably most of the money
that goes into this is public
money state
money and that the state should have the
ability to audit
it uh do you have any idea yourself
apparently people involved in it are get
more transparency than others on how
what part of the money that they use
comes from the state well let's back up
on that because keep in mind that all of
the money that's contributed to that
fund is contributed by private
businesses or
individuals and then ultimately what
happens is uh that money is in that
block and then the state turns around
and says okay we will reduce the tuition
reimbursements to the cities or towns
for every individual that is taken out
of that
system all right so the reality is the
money is not it it actually works to the
state's Advantage for every individual
that is taken out of the the the public
system from a financial
standpoint all
right follow up I do not think you
understand uh the structure of financing
for public
education because when you take five
children out of a school you cannot take
away any of the fixed costs including
all the salaries in that school it's not
sufficient to be able to take even one
child worth
out but when one child comes out of the
school does the state no longer have to
reimburse that that
District I believe that that is now the
law which means that the local
population has to pay more and our
property taxes go up or they have to
reduce their school sizes and and act in
an efficient manner correct no because
EXC excuse me repres me um we will
debate this in um in the
committee uh thank you uh Mr Matthew for
your
time is there anyone else who would like
to fill out
a pin card and speak seeing none I'll
close the public hearing on HB
483 okay there's only one speaker for
503 okay
uh well it should be to I should have it
um when did you send it can't listen to
him I was going to give you a hard I
just sent it probably five minutes ago
there it is okay all right thank
you Tom's introducing okay we'll open
the public hearing on HB
503 and uh representative shamberg
you've said you need 15 minutes to speak
I'm hoping that you can I've practiced
this at home be more
concise thank you Mr chairman and
members of the House Ways and Means
Committee for this opportunity to
present the concept of House Bill 503
and its Amendment at the recommendation
of the Dr I am state representative Tom
shamberg of maram 6 representing the
towns of Wilmont and Sutton for the past
six years I have introduced and
presented property tax releas approaches
concerning the cost of public education
on homes and businesses property taxes
today our legislature and the people of
our state are faced with the inevitable
reality of Republican leadership a
budget crisis and skyrocketing property
tax increases to pay for their CEO
handouts for the last 30 years here in
New Hampshire the Democrats have only
had control of the State House of
Representatives only three times the
last in 201920 202 as a matter of fact
the Democrats of New Hampshire have only
had control of the House of
Representatives three times in the last
50 years the considerable budget and
financial Issues new New Hampshire is
suffering from is clearly a cause of
poor Republican budget policies and
priorities revenues that have been
slashed for a decade Revenue cut that
favor the most wealthy Among Us are
coming dangerously behind projection and
departments are preparing cuts to
operations and services which will only
be downshifted onto local property
taxpayers that's on our neighbors who
are already feeling the pinch of rising
cost for Health Care energy Child Care
and housing we are hearing from towns
and cities alike the state is
downshifting costs that are forcing
budget committees select boards and town
councils to raise property taxes across
the board that sentiment is not just
mine on its Public Access television
show last last month Republican leader
and Manchester Alderman Joe Kelly lisar
said that when the state claimed to be
lowering taxes it really meant higher
property taxes for the rest of us which
he knows about since Manchester has seen
the highest property tax increase in a
decade with a Republican mayor in charge
granted Staters are working hard but
aren't getting ahead or even getting a
breather while billionaires and big
businesses are getting richer than ever
we can all agree Working Families and
people deserve a system that works for
you not against you New Hampshire is
just beginning to escape the horrors
that happened in the last time we
slashed the vital services like DCF now
we are hearing rumors on 10% or greater
cuts to all agencies including DCF all
because the Republicans
prioritize tax cuts for the ultra
wealthy granted Staters believe our
states economy is either stagnant or
declining and this is not an accident
but the direct result of a republican
built system at favors the rich CEOs and
multinational corporations that leaves
the rest of us paying the bill with
skyrocketing property taxes and Rising
costs like representative Opel stated
when presenting House Bill 502 speaker
will on complete corporate
reporting I'm sorry sir uh ask produce
the bill not engage in a uh diet tribe
sir I think this relates right to the
bill it you haven't yet told the
committee what the bill does or its
purpose can I have a copy of the Builder
the bill amends how revenues from taxes
are allocated to the education trust
fund I would rather not be here
today in front of you but it is clear
that the majority party that controls
the levers of state government are not
bringing solutions to the crisis they
started here and are responsible for
representative people are not getting
what they deserve while corporations and
alter Rich are contributing their fair
share
representative yes Mr
chairman let me be clear just a second I
take a breath here so I can get a full
lung of air to
speak um I am speaking for my residents
of Wilman and Sutton who have asked me
to present their views on this bill this
is better presented as unanimous consent
or personal privilege this is not a
place for a diet trbe this is for a
discussion of what the bill
does what does the bill do how does it
do it and why should it pass not what
this party or that party or the or the
green party in their windmills did I
that's not important thank
please what does the bill do how does it
do it and how does it well
benefits because it's reallocating funds
fine but let's get into specifics of the
Bell please thank you
please yes Mr chairman I will try to
smooth this out a little
bit
when this bill is for trying to stem the
rise of hikes in education property
taxes and
when it is
addressed against
my residents of Wilman and Sutton that
it is their
fault I say there is a misconception or
someone is
lying when leadership of the majority
ority
party says of the karge Regional School
District community members which Sutton
and Wilman are a part
of quote perhaps if they're unwilling to
cap themselves the state will step in
and cap local taxes for them that
infuriates
me when the leader of this majority
party who is an advocate for own
personal freedom wants to dictate what
others should do and is willing to use
the power of the state legislature to
overrule local control and local
decisions I stand in opposition and
that's why this bill was brought
forth I am here because I am committed
to ensuring that we are doing what we
can stop property tax Heights and not
raise a dime of taxes on the Working
Families and people of New Hampshire we
need a solution for local property tax
relief for public education
if you expect the corner office of this
state to stop local property tax Heights
think again what we have heard from the
new governor so far is nothing but
threats of belt tightening and severe
cuts to our agencies without seeming to
care how that would affect many of the
hardworking Granite
sters the least Among
Us in
conclusion why do we need to find
property tax
relief a the status quo is bankrupting
our state and putting the American Dream
Out Of Reach for far too many Granite
Staters B this is about ensuring that
those who benefit from our shared
Society also contribute to it C the
corporations and the ultry rich are not
the enemy but we do expect them to pay
their fair
share D we must invest in our
communities and strengthen New Hampshire
for the long term making it a place
where seniors are taken care of families
can Thrive and our children have real
opportunities to build a future and E by
working together we can create a more
just and prosperous future for all
Granite Staters and finally I am open to
suggestions for how to a avoid cuts to
essential services and ensure that
everyone is contributing their fair
share while also keeping property taxes
down I have a Britain statement for the
clerk thank you representative shamberg
uh will you take questions no I will not
thank you
uh all right uh next I have John
Reynolds thank you Mr chair and members
of the committee I appreciate the
opportunity to testify today
uh my name is John Reynolds I'm the
state director for the national
Federation of Independent Business uh we
are a nonprofit nonpartisan organization
that represents more than 1700 small
businesses across the state um we're
here to testify in opposition to uh
House Bill 503 um I think in a prior
testimony with the committee uh I
discussed how the recovery curve from
the pandemic looks a lot different for
our members for small businesses than it
did for larger businesses and they
struggled you know years after after the
pandemic started and in the most recent
uh small business survey uh called small
business economic trends that nfib put
out just yesterday inflation Supply
costs labor costs worker shortages are
still huge huge problems for small
businesses um and on top of that they're
facing the loss of a very important uh
Federal small business tax deduction at
the end of this year um if I understand
the bill correctly I believe it would
raise uh business taxes by close to $700
million over the next next three years
and this is only going to exacerbate
those challenges for for small
businesses across the state um
ultimately much of that tax increase
will fall on consumers and on workers um
and that just puts the squeeze on our
members even more uh because their
customers are struggling their workers
are struggling they're struggling to get
by um so we certainly hope that the
committee will find that bill as
inexpedient to legislate no just leave
it there thank you thank you very much
any questions seeing none thank thank
you uh and the final pin card I have is
Sarah
Scott thank you Mr chair and members of
the committee for the opportunity to
testify here today my name is Sarah
Scott and I'm the deputy state director
for Americans for Prosperity here in New
Hampshire and I'm here today in
opposition to
h503 uh the tax relief that we've seen
over the last decade has left New
Hampshire with the fastest growing
economy in the Northeast and one that is
the Envy of our neighbors this has made
New Hampshire more competitive and
improved the quality of life for our
citizens we should be praising this work
not reversing it passing this bill would
take us backwards it would leave us with
among the highest business taxes in the
country something that we've worked hard
to fix over the last 10 years and make
us less attractive Not only would we
stop seeing the influx of new employees
and jobs but we likely lose companies
who would flee such a hostile
environment and additionally make no
mistake this is an income tax bill we've
just achieved being a truly no income
tax state let's not ruin that progress
let's keep New Hampshire income taxfree
so it's for these reasons that we ask
you to oppose this
legislation thank you uh represent elme
thank you on we have major problems with
the Bia at least uh understands with um
uh housing lack of housing therefore
lack of workers on with child care
therefore lack of workers on and other
things
on what how do you expect that we can
deal with this when we keep cutting
taxes could you explain the question you
asking about how we'll afford the
spending how how we will manage really
this bill to increase taxes on granite
Staters would do just the opposite of
that and would cause even more harm to
the families that are coming into the
state um when you look at the issue of
housing I think that has to do a lot
with regulation um and so definitely a
separate issue than what we're
discussing here today but when you look
at the ability for families to provide
um whether it's the cost of housing
groceries Child Care the more we
continue to tax them I think the harder
it is for them to stay in the state
we're going to see businesses leaving
the state um if we were to increase
business taxes like this I think you
would see an influx of businesses moving
to uh different parts of the Northeast
you would see jobs leaving with that
which would make it a lot harder to
provide any other
questions seeing none thank you thank
you all right that's all I have for pin
cards is there anyone else who would
like to
testify seeing none I'll close the
public hearing on HP
503 so we went from uh 50 minutes behind
to eight minutes
behind uh
so um at this point we will take a lunch
break and come back at 1 pm and hear our
last public hearing of HP 669 thank
you
e
e e
the time being 107 I'm going to open the
public hearing on hp6
69 and um welcome representative
Smith thank you Mr chairman it's a
pleasure to be here in front of ways and
means I've spent lots of time in front
of Finance talking about where the money
should go and maybe not enough time in
front of ways and means about where the
money should come from but I'm delighted
to be here and and to see um my
long-term colleague the ranking uh
member representative Army as I look
around the room I think that we are
perhaps the only two people who were
here when the
equalized rate of
$660 for the state wide education
property tax was established and so
we've been here through the ups and the
downs
and who knows we might actually finally
be able to resolve this um I did notice
that it that this bill is on schedule to
be exact next week I'm hoping that
that's because the chair decided that it
was so clear and made so much sense that
he'll be ready to to pass it and and if
not then at least I would hope that he
would uh join with his colleagu is here
to retain the bill because in fact in
the fullness of time um the day is going
to come when the decision will be made
that we ought to do something that is
constitutional and this bill does that
it is a simple bill now I don't know
about you but when um someone comes
before my committee right now it's
Judiciary and says it's a simple bill I
roll my eyes because I know uh oh we're
in for trouble but the fact is this is a
simple bill and it's a simple bill that
the Simplicity of which is supported by
our wonderful
Professionals in the um in the LBA and
if you look at the if you read the bill
which isn't too long and you look at the
um at the fiscal note you could see how
easy it would be do do to take the
transition to finally figure out a
constitutional way to um to address the
issue of how we fund
education um this bill raises money and
that's why we're here and not down the
hall it does not have anything to do
with spending money that's for the other
guys to figure out this bill sets a rate
of $5 per 1,000 of equalized property
valuation it does not matter what town
you live in what city you live in it's
recognizes that this is a state tax and
under the state
constitution uh um we believe in in
equal responsibility and that's all that
this bill does in fiscal year
2026 it would raise about
1.62 billion that's b as in boy billion
per year which is approximately 1.26
billion more than in the current
$363
million all swept Revenue would be
remitted to the education trust fund not
retained locally as is the current
practice this is a state tax it is not a
local tax it is not a county tax it is
not a school tax it is a state tax and
therefore the State Should collect the
money and have a direct say in then how
that money gets
distributed um this does in fact
eliminate the opportunity for
municipalities to retra to retain what
has been euphemistically and
inaccurately referred to as excess swept
there is no excess swept um just as
there are no donor Towns at least if
there is a donor town I don't know where
that is I come from Durham and in Durham
we actually have to pay our own property
taxes the town does not pay those taxes
for us the city does not pay them we pay
them as property owners and so in fact
it is not the
town um which is donating anything
um the town money was never the town's
money what this does is ensures that all
taxpayers throughout the state no matter
where they live will pay the same R rate
as required by the New Hampshire
Constitution there would be a cost a
one-time cost of
$300,000 for uh Dr to um implement the
electronic filing and payment system
that's it this solves two identified
problems certain property wealthy
communities retaining state tax money
and using it for purposes that the tax
does not exist for and negative local
tax rates for schools in
unincorporated um locations where we
give money for no reason having to do
with the purpose of a Statewide property
tax the school districts are struggling
with ever increasing burdens of Health
Care energy and retirement expenses in
addition to their core purposes the
costs of special education have
increased and the burden is borne
unequally this bill does not spend any
money but it's passage could create
opportunities for the state to undertake
paying for special education it could
also provide Statewide assistance to
reduce the swept burden on low and
moderate income households it could do
it in a way that is
constitutional
Equitable fair and actually given the
fact that we have been able to solve
this problem for many many many many
years might be a way to get us to yes
and I hope you will give this bill every
every consideration I um distributed but
I wasn't quite careful enough I think a
little party favor to each of you um in
which um with your own you could see
your own town or the town you live in
even though you might represent more
than one town um the how the swiftt
uh payments have fit into
um our inequitable system that that we
have now this material was prepared by a
former um uh representative
distinguished Republican who actually
taught me how to read a
budget many years ago 30 years
ago and of course if he hasn't taught
you yet I will tell you one big TR
begin at the back of the budget read
that first and then go to the front but
that is um uh he will he will be uh he's
here and he will be testifying and um he
has prepared for the clerk a detailed uh
summation of these individual reports
that I've shared with you and would be
happy particularly for those of you who
represent more than one town to um to
give give you any additional information
that you want um I um and I think that's
all I I have to say if you have any
questions I'm glad to answer them thank
you um do we have any questions
representative Southworth uh thank you
and welcome to ways and means thank you
representative yeah um I might have
missed it um did you say there was
eventually going to be estimates for the
individual
communities um
representative well no wait a minute
what I've showed you terms of the
collection oh communities wouldn't be
collecting it no no what the money will
go yeah just as as we all as you know as
we we pay the taxes and this for the
first time will have the money clearly
go where it belongs to the education
trust fund and it will not be by town or
city or School District it will be by
the person who pays the
taxes in fact the man behind the
tree okay so follow up so I understand
the $5 figure I just mean has anyone
tried to play out as they did previously
with the different levels of towns and
so on you had an idea you know who the
23 towns with ex you know all that I I
to me that's course that's totally
irrelevant since in fact the towns never
have paid and do not and will not pay
the taxes there are um very good
research organizations that exist in the
state and I'm not sure exactly who um in
in addition to representative hall for
representative Hall who will testify and
they might know about that I don't
because I've always orted um uh I don't
believe in donor Towns now follow up too
against my religion I would just suspect
and maybe I didn't word it correctly
that um Representatives would be very
interested um whether they support this
or not of how it impacts their
constituents that's really what I'm
asking um I I hear you but it will it it
will depend upon what what the property
value is that there each individual
constituent um is responsible for and
that's how it will affect them it does
not affect people town by town city by
City School District by School District
so the other is you know could be for
amusement but I would suggest to you
that people who have property that's
worth
,000 will pay $5 and if they have
property that's worth a million you can
do the math yourself and it's person by
person property owner by property owner
it is not relevant at all to um to a
city or a
town okay representative
Aly
hi
on
there's uh I found your chart which
maybe you haven't looked at the last
page of this uh gives the percentage of
property tax for schools raised by the
tax at an equal rate everywhere which I
guess is five bucks um yeah and it's
different for each of us because it's a
different town but um I'm wondering you
will remember I think you were having to
sit in the back at that point but uh you
will remember that when we did this the
first time we decided that we we thought
that we would um make make the
payment come through
the um I'm trying to remember I'm full
it went to the town in the depending
upon where you live I mean for example
in Durham we have a CO um a Cooperative
School District so the money went to the
town of Durham of Lee and of Madbury and
then the school District had a formula
for how much each had to contribute and
that then went on and meanwhile the
towns got the float not the state even
though it was State money the towns got
the float and this to me is an example
it's actually my prime example of the
value um of lobbyists in this in this
state we don't have our own staff here
in the house except for the wonderful
LBA a which you and the finance
committee benefit from um we depend upon
lobbyists do a lot of the work and the
municipal Association it was then a
slightly different Incarnation but the
municipal Association was very very
clever they in they really pushed to
have the money go to the cities and
towns which got the float and which by
the way also got extra money to pay for
the computer capability that they would
need all of that on what is a state tax
and
um you have to decide whether you think
that that was the best thing to do
whether it's worked well or not I would
suggest to you it hasn't I'd suggest to
you that I would never prejudge using
the word judge amusingly um what in fact
the judicial branch will do but if I had
to bet I would bet it will be sooner
rather than later that there will be a
decision that says enough is enough we
need to have a tax a state tax
system that under the existing New
Hampshire
Constitution requires that everybody pay
the same rate without regard to where
they live not the same bottom line but
the same rate and that's what's
important follow up yeah but it it
sounds like you're continuing with the
idea that it's the municipalities that
are going to identify the property of
everybody in in the
municipality and send a bill to them
collect the money and then ma Mass it up
count it and send it straight to to uh
the treasur office that's a good
question representative Aly it's not
quite how I understood it my
understanding was that what the
Department of Revenue
Administration would do um as part of
its
um usual work of um of setting rights um
would do that and the money would go to
the education trust fund and um
in terms of the period is it every five
years that is it every five years now
that they have to uh reass I think it's
for every five years you know nothing of
that changes now maybe that should or
shouldn't but this doesn't deal with
this this only because it's a simple
Bill all it does is raise
money using what a number of us believe
is
constitutionally require and that is um
a same rate regardless of whether you
live in um regardless of where you live
doesn't matter Rich poor
whatever one of the things that I
particularly like about this bill
representative Aly is that it because of
the the reasonable $5 is below the 663
that we started with at one point um uh
and of course that figure can be be
adjusted that it is conceivable that
there would be enough money raised to
address the
problems uh faced by
um individual property
tax payers at the
lower end of the income scale I mean
there might be a mean but that would
then affect everybody also it would see
anybody at this level of income could
get a break in effect in in the and we'd
still have enough money to do what we
ought to be doing by the way this
number you know you know we're 50th in
the country for what we're spending uh
this number of this this Revenue figure
would put us at about the middle of all
states in the United States and wouldn't
it be nice that for this at least we
wouldn't be first and we wouldn't be
last it would kind of be like the Three
Bears you know not too hot not too cold
just
right yeah I'm I'm looking at section
two on lines 3
to8 and it it looks to me like it's
still going to
be assessed locally
and collected locally and then sent to
the
state
um I'm glad you're on ways and wings and
I'm not I don't see it that way but um
I'm I would yield to people behind me I
don't know if there's someone here from
Dr I don't know if there's someone here
I do know there are people here from
some other organizations I can't answer
that representative thank
you representative
y thank you to kind of follow up on it's
good to be here thank you representative
it's always good to see you thank you
ma'am uh almost over that's
okay following up on what representative
Aly just
said if the is required to set in
paragraph one a certain C
fee or a certain dollar
value that's not part of your bill but
part of the law then we modify
it to be
$5 what do we number one what do we do
with the
excess if there is any or what do we do
if there's an underage if there is
any and thirdly
how's it is is the distribution going to
change is this going to do what you
intend for it to do is is the ultimate
question this bill is very
narrow all this bill addresses is how we
raise the money in order
to
conform with what many of us believe is
our constitutional
obligation what happens after that
is respons is is the
responsibility of the people down the
hall um turned around now because I'm
not in the regular meeting down the hall
that way um in the new fancy education
committees and down the hall the other
way in finance how they choose to spend
that money related to
education is in you know for them but
all I'm trying to do here is to have a
constitutionally uh
appropriate
binding way of
raising money that means that no matter
where you
live you have each person each taxpayer
in the state pays at the same rate not
the same
dollar but the same rate and this
doesn't address any of the Myriad
questions it doesn't say okay if we
raise this money then maybe we could um
we could this will get some of you very
happy maybe we could lower another tax
or two um or maybe we could undertake to
um address the problems of people with s
with limited incomes or maybe we can
remove the financial responsibility of
special education from each school
district and have the state take it or
maybe we could um address the long-term
problems of uh the physical
deterioration of school buildings or
maybe we could return to the way that
the state had once supported uh
retirement for uh for teachers there are
all kinds of things that the other guys
could do all this does is say in a fair
and Equitable and constitutional way we
would be raising money that is State
money that would be in the control of
the State education trust fund for those
decision makers charged with those
responsibilities to make the necessary
decisions follow
up
yes oh that thank you very much this was
very nice can I leave now yes I I
understand what you're trying to do
however I'm kind of suspicious that it's
you know you're kind of number one the
requirement for any taxation is as
professorn repeatedly thanks
to uh representative only when she was
the chairman drummed into people it's
got to be equ and
proportionate this appears to be
Equitable that is it's the same and is
proportionate because it's proportionate
to each one don't need to have an
equalized value because it's based
strictly on whatever the town assesses
your property at that's your assess
local
assessment so that's fine but it's going
to ra if it raises a pot if it raises a
pot of money
and it goes into the education trust
fund then the distribution of the F of
the funds or how it's proportionally set
out isn't clear as
to whether this is going to
raise the funds that you wish and the
follow on question to that wouldn't it
then make it exceptionally easy
in a budget reconciliation activity to
races from five to five and a half to
six to six and a half to seven to 8 to
20 on the part of succeeding leg with
what I would say in response to that
representative ol is not if you're still
here and on the ways
in times are limited well I I understand
that but you know if we can
I mean we are
responsible for setting the policy of
the state and sometimes we make the
right decisions and sometimes we make
the wrong decisions and sometimes we
make decisions that are right at one
point but the world around us changes
and so too to those people who are
elected and we see that every two years
and uh
uh this isn't going to change that this
isn't going to change the fact that the
legislature is responsible for setting
the
policy thank you any other
questions seeing none thank you um oh
I'm sorry has been on a while know it's
a blind spot I understand oh it's
just thank you for taking my question
again I did figure out the answer to the
other I can just take several people's
incomes and do the and have an idea of a
high middle low so I understand that now
um so I think you really clarified that
you're raising the funds they are going
to um the education trust fund um would
you agree um that your next goal is
really to have a fair distribution chart
like we've had before so you know that
you're wanting to have a chart um that
really helps the state as a whole and
certain needy sections like special it
or whatever you're turning it over to
someone else but would that be your hope
representative
Southworth I believe strongly in the
importance of public
education in in a democratic small D in
in a democracy I think that it is Our
obligation as adults not just as
legislators to do everything that we can
to meet the educational needs of
everybody in this state um I how best to
do
that varies I mean I will tell you right
off for example that um there are not a
lot of people in um in the caucus I
preside in who are enthusiastic about
public charter schools I happen to be a
supporter of public charter schools
because I believe that having choices
about how um a particular child can best
learn are important as long as when we
are using public dollars our dollars
there must be standards there must be
accountability there must be
transparency
um all of that I think is important but
I'm not going to say therefore this it
must be X Y or Z I won't do that and um
uh look if I were you know if I had my
brothers I would say I was in charge and
I would make all the decisions and you
know I'd be happy with all the decisions
but that not being the world that I live
in I continue to be willing and maybe
I'm naive I continue to be willing
willing to trust in the ability of
people with disperate views with
disperate backgrounds with disperate
goals to figure out how responsibly to
come together and not to create a
perfect world but to at least move us in
the right direction thank
you now seeing no more questions thank
you very much thank you very much and do
remember my suggest gestions for next
week when you expect this Bill thank you
thank
you um representative
wheeler thank you chair janigan I have
the uh coveted position of getting to
follow representative Smith on this
piece of legislation so
I'm here today as a co-sponsor I think
representative Smith handled this
conversation quite well just to affirm
my support for the fair rate that would
be set up in this
legislation uh to bring a little
personal story forward I grew up in the
manad region born in Kean I went to
school in the conval school district
and while we had a great well-funded
School with a lot of opportunities and a
lot of different uh venues open to us as
students right down the road 10 minutes
down the road in the neighboring town of
Jaffrey they had about 10 times less the
opportunities and the pathway for
Success that I did simply because of the
unequitable rate of the funding for
Education uh that to me is just an
unacceptable reality for the kids in our
state because it leaves people with the
Hales and the haves knots uh the halves
and the haves knots that's a tongue
twister and I don't think that's an
appropriate situation for our state
especially given the fact that we in our
Constitution have education and a good
education as a founding tenant to the
state so chair janigan that's all I have
to say I believe in a fair rate for all
taxpayers in the state of New Hampshire
as opposed to shifting that burden onto
certain towns as opposed to others the
burden if we are going to have a
Statewide education tax should be
Statewide thank you Mr chair questions
from the
committee and I'm specifically making
sure that uh representative southworth's
light is not on thank you representative
Willer okay next up representative
Maguire
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee for the record my name is Dan
Maguire I represent the town of
Epsom to me this bill is like a big
slice of chocolate cake it's extremely
tempting um If This Were to pass it
would certainly make my life as a member
of the fin
committee way way easier than it is at
this moment right this bill
um will
raise another what is it $800 9900
million doll or something that's we
don't have going into the budget right
now and the budget is extremely tight I
mean we're we're at the you know looking
under the couch cushions for loose
change type type of stage here and
um
but it's you know and and there's parts
of this bill that I certainly will vote
for and and are in other bills um going
along with the Rand decision I think is
correct I I think the Court's ruling uh
and Logic on the Constitution is correct
on that one um so that's that $28
Million number that you see in the fisc
note um we have that in I'm also a
member of the education funding
committee we have that in two other
bills in front of our
committee um you could you could
certainly argue that that having a fixed
dollar amount of $63 million for
Statewide property tax is you know it
was set many many years ago certainly
there's been inflation since then when
we were working on the budget we use
2019 as a as a kind of a base to to kind
of get before Co and and up to today and
there's been just in those six years
there's been 25% inflation so so you
know you could easily argue that that
you know that number should be 500
million or something like that um but
but to have a tax increase of that
magnitude um though you know our cens
are going to have to would have to pay
it I mean it's it's just um it's it's a
lot more money uh collected now um You
can argue well if if um all we're going
to do is rebate that money to to other
taxpayers right to others that that are
um um paying less uh State white
property tax or or more local property
tax and some of that will happen right
so I think should this bill pass in this
current form um some of it will will end
up going back either to you know
directly to those taxpayers or or to
towns um I mean
schools
but I have a feeling
that given the way we are with the with
the budget um not all will you know some
of it will be used to um to fill some of
the holes that we have in the budget and
that that will be a real tax
increase um I I came in Sor at the tail
end of of some of your discussion I do
think if if it's an issue and you were
to implement something like this it
would have to be based on equalized
valuation not on sort of nominal
valuation and I'm not sure that's
correct in the bill as is um
and uh what else
um anyways I guess I'm I'm happy to
answer questions I I it's this is a
tough subject I I would suggest if
you're the final committee on this that
there are some bills from my education
funding committee that that have a
chance to pass and and will come here as
a second committee perhaps so you might
want to wait and and not EXA this
tomorrow tomorrow I don't know I don't
know if this is like an early bill from
your point of view or not um so I'm
happy to answer questions it uh to
answer your question it is an early bill
so it will go to finance is that it okay
most likely all right so maybe that
that's the you know we'll we'll get a
whole bunch of these kind of bills in
finance and then and then we'll we'll
merge them and and shuffle them um one
thing if you if that we will deal with
if assuming it passes education funding
is we have a bill that
um that imposes a uh school budget cap
um along with this kind of an idea right
so so more money coming in but you can't
spend more and therefore uh it all has
to go out to to other you know property
taxpayers basically kind of you know uh
flatten the the curve of of property tax
I guess um and so that's another another
thing we'll have to think about
representative
y thank you thank you for taking my
question If This Were to pass it's kind
of the same question I asked
Representatives If This Were to pass it
would create a big chunk of money going
into the educational trust
fund if it's in the education trust fund
it has to stay there it can't come out
correct yes and it would continue to
build and continue to build so there
would be this huge amount of money in
the educational trust fund the purpose
would be to spend
it and the qu and the reference was made
to New Hampshire being 50th as far as
money is being spent but I think we're
somewhere in the top qu or quarter of
states that
regarding educational
Excellence so we're spending Less in
getting a better result okay thank you
for the question let me let me get into
that so what they what they people
commonly say is we're in the top five in
results all right I personally think our
results are pretty horrible it's just
that we're in the top five compared to
even worse right elsewhere right so so
the actual numbers in terms of uh these
standardized tests that are used all
over the country are that roughly 50% of
our students can read at grade level and
and only about 40% can do math at grade
level so those are horrible horrible
numbers in my opinion but um they are
what they are and and like I said other
places are even worse so so I wouldn't
rest on our laurels in any sense of of
the word
um your other question about the
contents of the of the education trust
fund you're right that the way the law
is now um the education trust fund is a
um non-aps fund and um if it ever ran
out it would get refilled from the
general fund but it doesn't go the other
way however the other taxes that we put
into the fund other than than Lottery
lottery has to go into the education
trust fund but we put a significant
amount of BET PT liquor you know Etc
monies into that fund um and that
there's no particular reason that we
have to continue those at the same level
I think it's likely uh were this bill to
pass that we would to some degree lower
that level of those other taxes going
we're going to have to do that anyways
because right now um that fund is is
flush with cash and the general fund is
under right I if I remember the numbers
right this current fiscal year is
projected education plus plus general
funds to come in at roughly 200 million
below plan um and you guys probably know
that number better than I do but but but
at the end of the the bium the the um
education trust fund is projected to
have over aund million left in it but
the general fund is a projected to have
negative uh 80 or 90 or something like
that right so
um so we're going to have to um readjust
what goes into you know what goes into
the education trust fund from business
taxes and other taxes it's it's
inevitable representative
elme thank
you
um I'm I had really thought before of
what how we had managed which we have a
couple of times to take money away from
the education trust fund when we could
use it better in the general fund um but
uh thank you for that
explanation on I am wondering you seem
to think that there's something valuable
in the bill itself not necessarily the
five
uh and that it would be used use ful in
your education policy
committee funding committee but
um it is an early bill and we have to
put something in a
blurb that would allow it to go forward
without liking some of the stuff that's
in it some of at least some of us so um
do you have any
suggestions uh yes thanks for the for
the question I well again whether this
particular bill goes forward or not we
like I said we we do have the Rand type
of stuff in at least two other bills in
front of my committee I expect at least
one of those to pass um the the other
part about changing the I mean this is
the main part of this is is changing the
million both increasing it and also so
changing it to um away from a fixed
dollar amount and toward a um a variable
amount well a um mill rate type of an
amount um that's up to you guys I mean
um I think as long as you make sure that
that it's equalized
valuation um it's not I don't I don't
think it would be horrible to be a mill
rate I mean that would tend to
um tend to take the inflation aspects
out of it right that it would it would
sort of um tend to tend to uh track with
inflation over time that's not a you
know that's that part alone is not super
objectionable to me it's more just you
got to look at this as a big tax
increase that's that's my main message
and so um are you comfortable with that
tax increase I don't know
so uh you're you're basically saying
let's say that we itl this bill you
already have other bills in the
committee that are addressing this
similar issue that address Rand
absolutely I don't know that we have
another bill that specifically changes
the 363 million so that aspect of
it
um
actually I'm not sure so um
maybe I I I can try to get back to you
on that part okay thank you yes
representative thank you Mr chairman
um representative my understanding is
that um whether we're in the top five
because of our achievement or in the top
five because the other 45 are
worse
um
I is based on the fact that the state of
New
Hampshire is 50th in terms of the state
contribution to public
education and so whatever success we
might
enjoy um
comes
mainly if not almost exclusively on the
backs of property
taxpayers um in my community those
property taxpayers are really struggling
we don't have the assessed
valuation that some other communities
some neighboring communities
have so I hope you will
understand that I find it difficult to
be able to go back to my district and
explain to them the belief here that the
education trust fund is
overflowing and yet there struggling
with property tax
bills to make sure that their kids have
a decent
education even though it's completely
dependent on the ZIP code that they live
in all I understand thank you for the
question and I had meant to to address
this a little bit more so um we are 50th
you're absolutely right we're we're 50th
in terms of State moving money from
state level taxes to education right
I don't think we're 50th or even close
in terms of the amount we spend for
Education right total spending on
education Statewide K through 12 is
approaching $4 billion dollar a year um
you know on public education so I mean
which is averaging about close to
$22,000 a kit so that's a lot of money
right I mean that that nationally is not
low so so but you're right only a small
amount of that is coming from state
level resources right so so perhaps you
missed my
point you are correct that we spend a
substantial amount of money on public
education in the state of New Hampshire
and whether it's the rest of the states
aren't as good as we are or we're better
than them whatever it is we're achieving
something
with those contributions with the amount
of money we spend but the amount of
money we spend don't you
agree is coming from property taxpayers
it is coming from towns and cities and
it's coming from places like my
town who struggle to afford to be able
to provide their
children with the best possible
education that they can afford and and
in some cases
recently have been attacked for doing
so yeah thank you for the question and
you you're absolutely right I mean the
the bulk of money spent is property tax
right even this this is property tax
right here right I mean you know that's
our biggest tax right I mean they we
don't have another tax I mean we have
business taxes and so on but they they
pale in comparison the property tax u in
terms of our you know that's our major
tax Source here and and for for a very
long time you know hundreds of
years um school funding has been a local
matter right I mean the um part one um
article six of the Constitution said
that the locality will hire teachers
quote at their own
expense um and it said that from when
the Constitution was adopted until
1968 right so you know schools are a
local thing right and so doing
this is a big change right I mean it's
it's it it changes it from a local thing
to a to a more of a Statewide thing and
that's going to I
inevitably affect local control and
things like that now one other thing
I'll tell you that I've learned about
education is that
um and I would suggest you go to um a
website called edun nomics edu nomics
it's from the Georgetown University in
Washington DC and they take the data
from our department of Ed and all the
other department of EDS around the state
and display it in a really uh accessible
way but they have displays where they
show um results in schools you know test
scores versus spending in schools down
to the individual School level so you
can look at your school and your school
and your school and see where you are
you know how's my test scores how's my
spending um per pupil and there it's
what's surprising about it is there's a
essentially zero correlation between
spending and test scores okay we have
some schools in this state are spending
$115,000 a kid and we have others that
are spending $30,000 a kid and and it
looks like a big you know polka dot or
something you know chart there isn't a
correlation where there is correlation
and and this you would expect is between
um sort of circumstance and test scores
right so if you're from a a
disadvantaged family you know this would
be what we would call free and reduced
lunch right so when those things are uh
when a high percentage of a school
students um are from disadvantaged
economically disadvantaged families they
have low test scores when it's when
they're from uh wealthier families they
have high test scores but you know
what that means is I think education
makes people wealthier right and so kids
are more like their parents right I mean
they're if they're good in school
they'll be in those uh higher levels and
if they're not so good in school they'll
be in the lower and those things carry
on but but in terms of just sort of
thinking that a poor performing school
if it spends more it will necessarily
move up the test score
uh level it'd be nice if that were true
but it it really doesn't seem to be you
know my last question uh representative
do you believe that test scores are the
only or even the best
measure of outcomes in
education I'm not sure I know enough
about that I mean um I I know
it's you know it's what it's the data we
have right so um you could probably look
at uh fraction going to college some of
that kind of stuff but but I would think
they would all sort of correlate um and
I don't know that any other kind of data
is is available so okay any other
questions seeing none thank you thank
you Mr
chairman next I have Douglas Hall
thank you Mr chairman I'm
gonna
really uh my
local State Rep um Sai isn't here today
the only other person on the committee
that I know is representative Aly up
there um I should give you some sense of
why I'm here and it has to do with my
background I was a member of this house
for four terms and in three of those
terms on the finance committee I was
responsible for school funding the
division
2 and this was for the Claremont
decisions when we had the old so-called
augenblick
formula and school funding was an issue
then just as it is an issue now um at
that time when I first one on that
committee the new governor Jud
Greg came to the New Hampshire house and
said we've got to cut the
budget Johnson unu had just left and Jud
Greg had taken over and it's not unlike
what you're hearing today which is the
next budget cycle is going to be a big
problem and Jud Greg's plan was to
remove all state funding from the public
schools with the exception of the
lottery so that was my first
inauguration with um the question of
school funding
um I only served four terms I decided
not to run again uh but then I became
the founding executive director of the
New Hampshire Center for Public Policy
studies and two years later the
Claremont decisions uh were issued and I
helped organize the first major
conference here in uh New Hampshire
about how to define and cost an adequate
education and watched the legislature
here go through um two years really from
1997 to
1999 trying to come up with a plan to
respond to those
decisions what I can tell you right now
is the plan that was passed in
1999 if everybody had left well enough
alone there would be no lawsuits in
front of the courts right now
a
$660 property tax equalized value and by
the way House Bill 669 does need to be
amended in that section two to make sure
it's clear that what's being described
as a $5 rate on equalized value but a
$660 rate would take care think of it if
if $5 raises an additional 1.2 billion
what would a 6.6 raise there would be
enough money in the education trust fund
if everything had been left alone to
have no problem in front of you in
regard to school
funding um the material I've provided
you um representative Smith gave you um
the one two charts for the town you live
in but on the material provided you I
put the all the towns from all the
committee members because I want to make
a point about
that first this bill solves three
problems it makes the
Statewide education property taxed at
whatever rate a valid constitutional tax
by making sure that everybody pays the
same rate that's important
it sets a fixed rate by legislative
action what other tax as Ways and Means
Committee what other tax do you give the
some state agency bureaucracy the
ability to change the rate from year to
year I don't know of
any at least no major tax the insurance
tax the communications tax the business
taxes they're Changed by legislative
action this bill would put the Statewide
property tax back in the same um set of
conditions it'll raise 1.26 billion of
additional Revenue above the
363 million that has been raised this
year the bill does not say how it would
be spent you've pointed that out uh you
understand that and that's important
because and it means that we can't
identify town by Town what would this
mean because we don't know what the
distribution mechanism would be and
here's where this year's
organization of the process is going to
be causing a problem in
1999 there was no Ways and Means
Committee
there had been an Appropriations
Committee and a Ways and Means Committee
for some years Appropriations being what
we now call Finance but in 1999 Ways and
Means was collapsed in one committee the
finance committee was responsible both
for raising the revenue and for spending
it so pieces fit together in that
committee this year you have your work
and you have at least two two Finance
committees the school finance committee
and and the large finance committee
trying to solve this problem of school
Finance so it's harder for you than it
was in 1999 in
1999 the bill that passed to set this up
was a Republican bill Don aitech was
Speaker of the House Neil Kirk some of
you may remember Neil it hasn't been too
many years since he's been here but Neil
Kirk was chair of that finance committee
and supported that bill House Bill
999 in in
1999 okay so on these charts that I've
given you I want to point out a couple
things for each
Town 1996 1997 1998 on the left side of
each chart that was the T local tax rate
for schools in those years
in each town and you will
notice that those tax rates before
reform were higher than the 1999 tax
rates after reform every town saw a
reduction in its property
taxes it can be
done
now second thing to look at in these
charts starting with 19 1999 you'll note
that the bar has two portions the black
lower portion or blue I guess in the
color ones the blue lower portion is the
tax the local school tax rate and the
lighter upper portion is the Statewide
property tax rate so when you stack the
two that's the total tax rate in that
community equalized tax
rate notice that in your town in all of
the towns here that in n in
1999 almost half of the property taxes
being raised in the town were
swept now go over to the far right 2023
the num the year isn't there but the far
right column notice that the Statewide
property ta tax the upper little piece
is less than
10% of the total property taxes being
raised for school what does that mean it
means that 20 some years ago 20 five
years
ago
20 25 26 years ago half of the property
taxes were being raised by an equal rate
paid by every property owner in the
state now it's only 10% of the property
taxes that fund school that are being
raised in a constitutionally valid
manner that's why there are two lawsuits
out there the conval lawsuit and the
Rand
lawsuit if House Bill
999 from
1999 were still in effect those
um those lawsuits wouldn't have been
necessary to be
filed and there'll be decisions coming
down hopefully in the next couple months
that are going to force some decisions
upon you and your finance committee
members and I would hope that you can at
least retain this
bill so that it's available if if the
New Hampshire Supreme Court makes a
decision issues its decision on
March 20th that you've got a bill that
you can work
with there's one other thing that I'd
like to well maybe two other things I'd
like to add uh one had to do with a
question about that uh representative
McGuire was asked about achievement
levels and yes New Hampshire students
are among the top five states in the
country when you use any of the sort of
readily available National achievement
tests and that makes us feel good did
you know that there are quite a few
school districts in this state where
those results are lower than the lowest
state in the
country the issue to be dealt with by
making education a state responsibility
which the Constitution requires is to
ensure that students no matter where
they are have an opportunity to achieve
well our average is good our
distribution is all over the place
because we rely on unequal property
taxes to fund the majority of
educational
costs I'll leave it at
that
questions representative Spar thank you
chair um the your your uh statement
three here in your front page
uh you said that uh this go uh allowing
for reduction of the same amount in
local property taxes if you're raising
1.26 billion for the State education
allowing for a reduction of the same
amount in local property taxes um but
that wouldn't necessarily apply for each
different town or District right you're
just saying that's correct so some some
towns will benefit more some will lose
more so uh I can tell you for just the
ones here um without the numbers on the
distribution but generally speaking the
communities with low property wealth per
pupil such as charl
town would benefit greatly and the
taxpayers there would benefit
greatly on the other
hand uh towns with high property value
per
pupil uh which there aren't many within
this committee by by the way the Lakes
Region towns and the uh Ry and um SE
Coast towns are not so well represented
in this committee but those towns might
well see an increase in their taxes but
how to actually calculate it it depends
on what the distribution mechanism is so
if the distribution of $800 million
which is about what special education
cost total costs Transportation
everything
okay if that $800 million is sent out
based
on each District's special education
cost you get one change in tax rate if
it's sent out by increasing the base
cost per pupil to $12,000 you get a
different change in tax rates until you
can match how the money in the education
trust fund is going to be
distributed you can't come up with exact
numbers for each uh
Town H if you were the king how would
you do it that we feel was Equitable and
also would P be palatable to all these
different uh taxing districts or
different value districts if if I were a
member of the house
again which I'm I'm actually glad I'm
not I don't think it to come in once
maybe a year uh if if I were a member of
the house I would say that special
education is one of the biggest problems
in education in terms of funding because
highly expensive kids can move from one
town to the next town and then back to
the town they were in and all of a
sudden this sets off cycling of budgets
that makes no sense so I would find a
way kind of an insurance policy that
every District pays into through its
Statewide property tax pays into the an
insurance policy and that insurance
policy just like fire insurance pays out
where the need is um that would be one
thing I'd do that take about $800
million
1.26 billion gives you another 400
million beyond the special ed so if it
were up to me I'd put 200 million of
that into a homestead exemption for
everybody give them $100,000 of
exemption on their primary residence
so that the property tax rate paid by
businesses and and vacation homes is
different from that on a person's home I
would do that and I might also increase
the base cost per pupil by another $200
million and see at the end how how does
that look how do we feel about
that other
questions okay seeing none thank you
very much
next I have Zach
Shen good afternoon my name is Zach
shien I'm the executive director of the
New Hampshire school funding fairness
project uh it's my first time in this
committee this year so for those of you
who don't know um we're a nonprofit
organization based here in conquered
primary purpose of our organizations we
do a lot of educational activities
around the state talking about school
funding property taxes some of the
history a lot of the stuff you've heard
today some of the potential policies
Solutions um and then we follow a few
bills each year that are related
directly to school funding and property
taxes um while that's being passed out
um just a few pieces I want to highlight
that have been said by previous uh
speakers uh House Bill 669 would solve a
number of the kind of constitutional
questions being raised by the school
funding lawsuit specifically the Rand
lawsuit um that decision around the
constitutionality of swept is pending a
decision in the Supreme Court and as
you've heard mentioned earlier uh could
be coming down any day at this
point uh also um by changing it from the
$363 million which is this locked kind
of arbitrary rate um or amount to a rate
would uh make it more of a true tax that
could be adjusted would keep up with
inflation changing
costs so what I've passed out um I
didn't set it up like this I assumed
this is where the conversation would go
I've kind of G taken a different
approach I've given a hypothetical for
what if this money raised by swept were
spent in a specific way so um what I did
was we took two Bills currently being
heard in front of the house education
funding committee uh House Bill uh 603
and House Bill 550 House Bill 603 um
would effectively pay for all special
education costs which actually um Doug
was just talking about about $800
million so just all expenses we are
currently paying for for special
education costs House Bill 603 would pay
for that house bill 550 would uh
effectively do the ruling in the con Val
lawsuit um which is from the Superior
Court ruling back from November 2020 3
um which would increase base adequacy
that's the amount going to every single
student in every school district from
the 4100 and change it is now to the
7356 in judge Ru off's ruing so
combining those two bills it's a little
more than what this bill would rais but
it's about 1.3 billion right so what I
wanted to kind of show was what would be
if you took that money in through this
um House Bill
669 in a true Statewide tax tax at 5
per thousand and then you turned around
and paired it with two bills that are
currently being considered that have
been proposed being considered in
another committee and sent that money
back to
communities and they didn't increase
their school budgets right because this
we're kind of talking about taxes what's
the tax impact so if they increased
their property tax rates that was paired
with increased funding from the state in
the form of these two bills that
increased fing the state they Ed to
offset their local property taxes right
this is hypothetical right if I could
wave a magic wand and have that be the
where it plays out which I think was
some of the earlier questions the impact
here you can see town by Town what the
overall school property tax impact would
be uh most school you know some high
level um pieces the median equalized
value um equalized school property tax
rate would decrease from currently it's
937 to
$811 um we'd see a shaving off of the
the communities that pay the highest
rate so no Community would have a
equalized school property tax rate
that's state and local combined above
$11 per thousand uh currently there are
81 communities that pay more than $11
per thousand all the way up to $16.10
which is Brookline right now 172
communities to see reduction 30
communities would see an increase of
under a dollar per thousand so there
would be some communities that see an
increase the vast majority would see a
decrease we'd really shave off the top
um the highest tax rate districts to
pull them down from that 16,000 dollar
per thousand to under
11 um obviously this is a hypothetical
but I try to use very real numbers and
data from two other school funding bills
um just to kind of give a sense of right
where this could go if paired with other
uh
elements a few more points I want to
make and then I'm happy to answer any
questions about this um you know what I
provided here or the bill in general um
I just want to
reiterate um that the you know the 50th
in the country piece is is the state
share and so what I'm kind of modeling
is what if we shifted without increasing
the size of the pi for total education
spending right so still about $4 billion
do what if we shifted some of that
responsibility from local property
taxpayers to the state right so that we
were no longer a 50th in the country but
as represent Smith pointed out somewhere
in the middle right and that's kind of
what I'm showing here in that shift not
an increase in public education spending
in particular um another Point around
concerns um around increasing property
taxes for some of the communities that
would not see an offset in the model
I've laid out we have other mechanisms
um Doug just mentioned a hom set
exemption there's also the low and
moderate property tax relief program
which I'm sure all of you are familiar
with that we currently have in statute
that we basically just don't fund right
that is an active program that we have
that provides property tax relief for
people in the state on their swept that
we don't put enough money into and the
limits are so low that it's not really
an accessible fund that average rebates
about $200 so that could be another idea
for making sure that individuals in the
communities that might see a tax
increase would um have the the rebate
and the relief there so their total tax
bill would uh would not change based on
their
income um the last piece I guess I would
want to make is just a comment that was
made by representative McGuire around
effectively money not having an impact
on school outcomes um that is not a
settled statement that is actually
highly disputed and there's a lot of
evidence that shows that money does
impact outcomes and opportunities for
students especially when taking into
account specific needs like to his point
if you're coming from a low-income
background we know that in general
students from low-income background
struggle and we also know that when we
have money invested in communities or in
school districts with higher proportions
of students with low income it has a
huge impact and return on investment to
kind of use that language so plenty of
evidence out there to show that money
does matter and especially when you
target it in a specific way um such as
special education needs or for students
coming from lowincome uh backgrounds so
those a few of those points happy to
answer any questions about the bill or
anything um I've handed out here
today any questions from the
committee seeing none thank you very
much thank
you the last pin card I have is uh uh
Bruce from Dr if we have does anyone
have questions uh for Dr
seeing none thank you for being
here is there else to do is there anyone
else that wishes to
testify on this
bill seeing none I'll close the public
hearing on HB
669 okay that concludes uh today's
public
hearings um before anyone leaves um we
want we're gonna hear from Chris Shay
who's got a whole bundle of information
in his hands
good for
don't e
so um Chris if you'd like to explain
I'll just go through real quick with you
so the there's two documents the one
that's uh dated February 12 2025 final
is basically a completion of the
document you've been seeing each day up
until today so it doesn't have the
splits in it it's just the everything
combined um a little bit easier some
sometimes to look at when you're trying
to look at the numbers the second one is
the um document that provides the
general fund education trust fund split
and if you go to page five you can start
to see that um under columns a b and c
there's your business taxes column A is
the general fund portion of that uh the
column B is the education trust fund and
then column C is the total of the two
that column C you should find in the
other report I
referenced um
so and that's how this goes through um
for each of those pieces or those taxes
that um are split which do include your
business taxes meals and rooms tobacco
R and meals and
rooms I did say meals and rooms so got
twice
um nothing new here other than the
splits but when you turn to page nine
that just provides you um the total so
column AC is the total as you've been
seeing all along and then if you turn to
page 10 you'll see the totals by funding
source so you'll see that column A is
the general fund portion of your Revenue
so that's the total that you've
estimated for each of those years and
then the um AE is the total for theed
education trust fund and then again
another total total that combines the
two so you can just see that everything
foots and ties um I
think just to point out because I was
listening to your the testimony that was
going on and um represent Maguire who
has not seen these figures yet um
suggested the education trust fund is uh
flushed with cash and we should end the
year with about $100
million um that was correct until you
guys finalized your estimate and if you
look at um row
seven in column AE you got 1. 1283
billion and then you look at row 10
column AE it drops to
1.89 billion so this you know almost a
hundred million drop that will eat up
any surplus that's remaining in the
education trust fund so I I just just
showing you how important the numbers
are that you're coming up with and how
this will be um probably looked at when
the other members start to see this
um so that that's it generally thank you
Chris where's the um uh that's the
education trust fund so the education
trust fund that one you know column AE
line row 10 you're saying
1.89 represents your estimate no I
understand but basically a break even
based on the way things are
tracking right it it would drain the um
potential Surplus that was in the
education trust fund so as as was
mentioned to the committee um the in
2023 when you looked at the Surplus
statement that we had at that time there
was an estimate there would be
approximately $230 million in the
education trust fund by the end of
20125 that has been um decreasing each
year partly because the revenues aren't
coming in on that side of the equation
as strong as they um should have or
could have as well as um some some of
the funding that comes out of the
education trust f for things
adequacy um Charter Schools efas all
which have um an open warrant ability so
that because they're all estimates the
ability to make sure that these three
areas pay for the children that they are
supposed to pay for so the commission
has an open warrant to take care of that
so you've seen some adjustments each
year related to that um but I just again
just wanted to mention it because I I
heard it in the last public hearing
um just at any opportunity we can get to
message that just so people understand
that um we may not be as flush with
money as we were you know a year ago or
even maybe six months
ago okay so then if we look at column A
on page 10 yep
um
ad I know now I'm asking a question
about the general fund um
so row seven is the official plan yes
sir row 10 is our estimate um so
obviously our estimate is about 62
million below the plan where are we
tracking on that one right now
uh so before your estimates here um we
had was Nor it was north of $25 million
deficit in general funds okay um I can't
remember the exact amount but we we
update it um every 30 days or so yeah I
think that's I think I do remember that
so so what you you've heard um is that
the governor has you know has a hiring
free she issued an executive order to do
hiring free so that's one way that the
executive um the governor's taking care
of the executive branch and trying to
control some of the U potential
shortfall in the general fund um there
may be other things that are occurring
or will occur in the next few months um
but it it is something to be keeping an
eye on you know going forward and and
you know for finance committee as they
start their work you know that's
something something that Mike Kane will
um continually be reminding them of is
you know status of where we are um or
anticipated where we are
yeah and then the last couple Pages
again are the highway fund and the
fishing game fund you guys completed
those the other day they haven't
changed um I will put these documents on
um our web page I didn't do that yet in
case there was some issue or concern
that you needed to change something
yes yes yeah I I caught it when I was
sitting in
next yeah
not a big deal no I I appreciate that I
I did catch it when I was sitting there
and I'd already printed the copy so I
was like let's leave
[Laughter]
it
Yep this is two mistakes in two days I
know I'm getting
older and huge
mistakes so I do have one other gift for
you when you're done talking about um
Revenue
news our our office uh completes our b b
anual report and uh as part of the
statute we need to deliver it to the
Ways and Means Committee members as well
so basically it gives a kind of a a
summary of our budget office as well as
our audit office some of the audit
topics that we've worked on there's
little blurbs for those to give you a
little bit of statistics on the number
of fiscal notes um our office deals with
um fiscal impact statements for rules
and just some of what our Duties are um
so just it's more of an interest read
you know tonight when you're at home and
you're looking for something to do yes
sir
question so this is an audit by
yourselves of yourselves it's just a
report not an
audit it's it's a moment to tell you all
the good things we've done you did a
good job yes all right before we before
Chris passes that out does anyone have
any questions or concerns about these
handouts because now the Next Step will
be uh for you to come on February 21st
with I'm sorry 19th y with a uh
resolution that's correct so if the
committee is okay with what they've been
presented today and they want me to move
forward I'll go do that yeah I mean I
looked at it last night I didn't see
anything different than what we um
agreed to yesterday but if somebody has
different thoughts you know let us know
but um yeah so at this
point baring any last minute changes I
think uh you know resolution would be in
order all right we'll do then and then
um we will be so then so on the 19th
we'll be executing the the resolution
and then um there's about eight bills
you'll actually I think it already came
out in in your email um you should
already have Wednesday schedule there's
like eight bills I think we're going to
exec after that and uh the Friday isn't
out yet but it's coming email is down
from want to understand so there'll also
be you'll see same thing scheduled for
Friday and again as I said yesterday
that's a snow date so because I don't
anticipate nor do I want to come in
Friday I think we can get it all done
Wednesday the
19th and that's Friday the 21st by the
way I'm talking about not this Friday so
um yeah so so we should meet on
Wednesday the 19th exec all that and
then um have the following week
completely off and then uh be back in
March and I'll you know that schedule
will come out sometime with the calendar
that comes out the end
of
February any any questions before we
move on to the final document here
okay it's not a
Rie no it's just a p just being passed
out so that that pretty much ends
today's
um meeting unless anyone has any uh
questions or concerns is there anything
you're going to talk to about this or we
all we're all set okay give it to
you
e e